i'm always
we'll do the standard three minute grace
period
thing that seemed to work okay before
by the way apologies in advance if i'm a
little bit frazzled i've just been in
back-to-back project meetings for the
last several hours and they all overran
uh and i may also eat conspicuously
during this lecture so
this is like the height of
professionalism
okay let me try doing screen sharing
do that we get to see mark
um
okay so it seems that we didn't quite
get the opportunity to finish um
discussing relativistic stuff last time
i'm going to just quickly take you
through
the last of what i wanted to say about
the gr derivation
and about things related to cosmology by
the way sorry for those of you who are
worried
i know this lecture is scheduled for two
and a half hours that's just
to ensure that we had a bit of a buffer
don't worry i have no intention of
speaking for two and a half hours
um i will i will finish probably quite
early uh so we can all take a break not
least because i
desperately need one um but
hopefully we'll be able to cover at
least some quantum mechanics today uh
anything we don't cover today we can
cover tomorrow
um yeah it's uh don't be concerned
okay so going back to the the derivation
i gave this morning
um we i kind of mentioned or i alluded
to the fact that this derivation of the
continuum einstein equations from kind
of discrete
causal network dynamics is somewhat
analogous to in fact the the
the ergodicity assumption we made is
directly analogous to
um the derivation of continuum fluid
dynamics the cont the derivative of the
continuum navier-stokes
equations from discrete underlying
molecular dynamics uh you know the the
the same ergonicity the same molecular
chaos assumption
uh has to be made in both cases and
actually mathematically
what we're doing is essentially the same
procedure so uh
for those of you for those of you who
don't know about that about the
derivation and by the way i should say
i'm not i'm not claiming to be an expert
on it either but to the extent that i
understand it
the basic idea in that derivation is you
start from a one particle distribution
function for some collection of
molecules
you construct the associated boltzmann
equation and then you introduce
this parameter epsilon so you so the the
on the right hand side of the boltzmann
equation where you
in front of the integral operator for
the inter of the called collisions you
have this one over epsilon
uh thing appearing and then the idea is
to just take
uh and to take the take the distribution
function
and expand in as a formal power series
in small powers of epsilon
and so what that translates to
ultimately in the hydrodynamic case
is like a kind of tensor power series
expansion so what happens is
if you if you take the zeroth order term
in the with respect to epsilon
you get a boltzmann equation that yields
the euler equations which are the sort
of dissipation-free versions of fluid
mechanics the
the the general dissipation free uh
statements of conservation of mass
momentum and energy
um and then if you go to a higher order
if you go to higher order terms if you
take the first order term
and so on then you get the full navier-6
equations with with dissipation
um and then you there's nothing actually
to stop you from going further in fact i
mean
uh various people including steven using
sort of cellular thomas and models of
molecular dynamics have gone about
deriving higher order extensions to
to sort of hydrodynamics so if you go to
the the next
uh level up the the second order
solution that yields the thing called
the burnett equations if you go to the
third
third order you get the superbinet
equations and so on there are all of
these sort of higher order supersets of
navier stokes
uh that one can consider um
now essentially what we're doing is like
exactly the same as
as you know in the relativistic cases
one does in fluid mechanics because
if you kind of if you run through the
mathematical arguments for the
hydrodynamic derivation
what's going on is you're taking the
total viscous stress tensor
that is that you know the the the the um
the tensor that describes the total
stress that's attributed to strain rate
in
in the sort of in the in the fluid or
whatever in in this in this idealized
fluid
and uh then you're saying we can take
this tensor and we can decompose it into
a sum
of a trace-free part uh which is a and a
trace part
right and so then the trace part which
is some scalar multiple of the identity
tensor
manifests as a bulk hydrostatic pressure
and then the trace free part manifests
as the as the
viscous uh shear stress so that that's
that's the the you know the stresses
that are not hydro
hydrostatic but rather have some shear
component to them and that's exactly
what we're doing in this relativity
derivation effect
implicitly what we did by essentially
doing this power series expansion which
is like a chapman enzog expansion
for for the um for the dimension and the
curvature of
the causal network is we would we were
taking the total riemann curvature
tensor
and we were decomposing that into a sum
of a trace part
and a trace3 part uh in our particular
case the trace part which
uh is like is some scalar multiple of a
linear combination of
of identity tensors of effectively
chronic deltas that's the ricci
curvature tensor that's the thing that
we were using
which is kind of the zeroth order term
um
in order to describe the growth rates of
the of the causal network
but then there are also higher order
terms which come from the from the
trace-free part
and in the context of the einstein
equations the trace free part of the
riemann curvature
is is what's called the vile curvature
tensor and so the important thing to
note is the ordinary einstein field
equations
don't they only place constraints on the
richie curvature and they leave the vile
curvature unconstrained and that fact
actually has
a bunch of implications for things like
gravitational waves and other things
like that
um and so the exciting thing is that
because we have an effectively
hydrodynamic procedure based on this
kind of space-time averaging of
dynamics across the whole causal network
we have this hydrodynamic procedure of
deriving the einstein equations
we also have a way of accessing and
probing these higher order terms
effectively like the analogues
of the of the navier-stokes burnett
superbenetic equations but for
relativity
and so in particular you know we only
considered growth rate with respect to
the second order contribution but we
could have considered growth rates
with respect to the higher order
contributions as well which would have
placed constraints on the vile curvature
and so the kind of you know this sort of
geometrical
picture of what what's going on there is
when we when we place constraints on the
reachi curvature
they're really they're effectively like
divergence constraints they're saying
that the
that there are certain conditions on how
uh gdc
on how the volume of a g86 bundle in the
causal network is is able to grow and in
fact so in the
in the in the vacuum case it's saying
that it's not allowed to grow it has to
that the volume of a gd6 bundle has to
remain constant
because if it doesn't running in cost if
if it grows you know if the gdc bundle
is allowed to have a
kind of monotonically increasing volume
then that will correspond to a causal
network that won't limit to a
to a finite dimensional space um and so
uh but but now we also have a way of
potentially deriving constraints for the
vial curvature
right so so um and so now what we're
this is a more fine-grained description
of what's actually going on in space
time where we're saying
there aren't just constraints on the
volumes of the g music bundles but
but actually on their shapes or almost
like we're kind of bright
and higher harmonics on on geodesic
bundles something like that
um so this is something that people have
considered in ordinary general
relativity there exists higher order uh
analogues of the einstein equations like
lovelock gravity that works in higher
dimensions that uses these high water
corrections
or higher order contractions of room
curvature i should say
which therefore do place constraints on
things like the wild curvature um but
you know things like lovelock gravity
have been explored for kind of
mathematical
interest only we potentially have a way
of actually deriving the
deriving these kind of theories actually
from first principles and
um i believe cameron's project is uh is
related to
attempting to do at least a kind of toy
version of this to see if at least in
certain small cases
uh we are able to derive effectively
higher order corrections to the einstein
equation where we
i mean we're even just kind of
phenomenologically we should be able to
see
what kind of constraints exist on the
shapes of geodesic bundles that are that
are permitted
in in the causal network i'm kind of
excited to see how that project
ends up going um so
one of the reasons why this is kind of
interesting is uh um
sort of what um i'm not yet sh okay this
is i i
should be completely upfront about this
this is a conjecture that sort of steven
made
that i'm still not completely convinced
of although it's certainly an
interesting idea
but stephen's sort of idea was that
these higher order corrections might be
related to dark matter that that somehow
you know
that they that they might constitute uh
it might be the case that the ordinary
einstein field equations that just
constrain the richie curvature
you know those might be a good
approximation for small you know for
relatively small scale problems but once
you reach kind of galactic and
intergalactic
scales you know these higher order
corrections might become more important
and
that you know that that might have
implications for things like galactic uh
galactic halos and uh galactic rotation
curves and things like that
um that's an interesting question we
don't really know the answer but it's a
possibility that it's possible that it
might be related to these
uh sort of modified newtonian dynamic
models of things like dark matter and
dark energy
that's that's certainly one possibility
um so what i
one one thing that you might have
noticed in this derivation is that
uh we've essentially been assuming i
mean as i've kind of kept
kept mentioning that that we've assumed
that that there's some there's some
limiting process to a finite dimensional
manifold there's some limiting process
where the causal network becomes
finite dimensional but uh there's
actually
you know when you have a network which
which not only does it not have a
geometry defined on it it doesn't even
have a fixed topology
unlike in ordinary differential geometry
there's no reason for you to assume
that the dimension is not also changing
that's not something that one usually
considers in differential geometry for
the simple reason that you know one of
the axioms of a manifold
is that the connected component that you
know effectively dimension
is a local invariant so all of the
connected components of the manifold
have to have
have to have a constant local dimension
they have to have a
equal local dimension you can't have
connected components for which the
uh for which the dimension varies but in
our models
that that condition is no longer
necessarily the case so
in doing this einstein field equation
derivation we kind of cheated a little
bit
by assuming that n was fixed and
assuming that r the
the richie scalar was the thing that was
varying but we could just as equally
have assumed that r was fixed and that n
was varying
and you know and effectively so instead
of having a second order correction
uh to to n we we would be dealing with
some exponential correction to n
and so you know something that would
something a a small
change in uh a small change in dimension
locally is kind of indistinguishable
from a large change in curvature
you know that you know it's just that
one is affecting n
in an exponential way one is affecting n
in in a quadratic way
and so uh it kind of leads to this
interesting possibility that maybe
there's a way of formulating
uh general relativity that works for
kind of manifold manifold-like
structures
but where the dimension is allowed to
vary both locally and globally
and so that's something again we don't
really know uh the the right
mathematical framework for thinking
about that uh i've
made a couple of conjectures about a
possible way of formulating it but it's
certainly not worked out in any detail
um because this is a purely conjectural
thing i'm not going to talk about it too
much but my basic idea
is in sort of ordinary differential
geometry you have this notion of a
coordinate chart
that's the this homeomorphic map from
open subsets in the manifold
to open subsets in euclidean space and
then curvature is then
so that that
the manifold into chord charts is a
connect finds and then curvature is some
measure of the degree to which the
connection fails to be exact
um and my my basic idea was that maybe
instead of thinking about coordinate
charts you could think about this more
general kind of
more general kind of uh of morphism
which is the thing called a covering map
in algebraic topology that's
that's a container of some smooth
subjection between topological space
x and what's called a covering space c
which under certain conditions becomes
this thing called a universal covering
space and then my kind of my idea was if
if you consider sort of if you consider
x to be like the base space which has
which is some some uh sort of manifold
some grid-like manifold-like structure
with fixed dimension and where you know
and where c the covering space is
is the is your is the hypograph you're
kind of considering
then you could you could imagine instead
of having uh that
you would have this generalized notion
of a connection where instead of a
coordinate chart
you would have uh something like like a
universal covering map
and then rather than thinking about
curvature as being a measure of the
degree to which the connection fails to
be exact
you're you're talking about uh sort of a
a kind of dimensional curvature
where it's it's measuring the the degree
of discrepancy between
you know put a point locally in in the
space that you're analyzing
and and the corresponding point in in
this space of homogeneous dimension
and so it's a way of locally
characterizing the degree of kind of
dimension discrepancy but that's again
like i say it's really just
it's um it's not it's not something i've
worked out in great detail
um the particular reason that i kind of
i thought that that might be a good
approach for thinking about general
relativity in variable dimensions
is because of an analog to geometric
group theory so
um the so in geometric group theory
obviously you have this concept of
of of cayley graphs uh kd graphs are a
particular example of what are called
vertex transitive graphs so to graphs
where every
every point has essentially the same the
same neighborhood structure
so here are examples of vertex
transitive graphs that we can think of
as being like the base
spaces for describing variable
dimensional gr that they are like the
base spaces
of of effectively fixed dimension and
then we're going to place something on
top of the base space that can have
varying dimension
and we're going to quantify it entire
we're going to quantify its curvature
in terms of the degree of discrepancy
between the between the local dimension
of the of the space we're analyzing
and the and the the global dimension of
the actual base space
and so uh so then as i say b because
cayley graphs give you a way of
constructing
uh vertex transitive graphs they give
you a way of constructing these kinds of
base spaces
um i i thought there was there was a
kind of there must be a kind of general
way of thinking about this this local
dimension change in terms of geometric
group theory
um and that we at least know one very
very toy version of that
which is the case of the relationship
between a beta lattice and its key graph
so the beta so if uh okay for those of
you who haven't sort of encountered uh
things like calligraphs in group theory
before
it's uh it's just a way of saying you
know every if if every
um if you have a if you have a graph
that's kind of that's that's finitely
presented
sorry if you have a group that's finally
presented you can associate to it a
finite caylee graph
where each where each vertex corresponds
to an element and each edge
corresponds to an application of a
generator to that to that element so
effectively it's a combinatorial way of
expressing the presentation of that
group
the sets of generators and relations um
and so
then it's pretty trivial to see that
they have to be vertex transitive
although the converse isn't necessarily
true
the the peterson graph is an example of
a of a graph that's the vertex
transitive but not kelly
um and then you can define this thing
called a beta lattice
which is an infinite graph a rooted tree
where every vertex has the same number
of neighbors so again
it's it's it's it has uh it's it's again
a trivially vertex transitive object
uh where um where the the neighborhood
structure is defined by this
this natural number this thing called
the coordinate the coordination number
and the interesting thing about that is
that the beta lattice is
uh effectively up to a factor of two is
the kelly graph for the free group on
on on that on the number of generators
given by uh
one half of the of the coordination
number
and so essentially you can think of any
presentation of a group as being a
subjective map from the free group on
on that number of generators back onto
the onto the original group and this is
this is essentially so this is an idea
that people study in geometric group
theory and this is the idea that i
kind of basically want to uh to see if
we can generalize
in the case of these hypergraph models
because the free group is like the base
space
it's the one a fixed dimension and then
if we have a group that where
you know the coordination number
effectively isn't uniform the the you
know the
the the neighborhood structure of the
vertex count isn't uniform
then you can think of that as being a
subjection from the free group
onto that onto that onto the the
caligraph of that group
and then you can define things in terms
of like you know then you can define
local changes of dimension in terms of
local changes in
in kind of neighborhood structure um
so anyway that's that was probably a
little bit incomprehensible and and it's
a lot it's
in part incomprehensible because i don't
fully understand it yet because i just
want to give a kind of
a conjectural idea for how local
dimension change might be formalizable
even though you know the mathematics for
this doesn't yet exist we're kind of
having to invent it uh more or less in
real time and so uh
and in fact we could we could go a
little the reason i put these pictures
in is to
illustrate that we um we could go a
little bit more general than this
because we're not
uh because our notions of dimension and
curvature don't depend on individual
uh gd6 individual adjacencies they
actually depend on kind of
on on average adjacency structure they
depend on finite length gd6 rather than
just single hyper edges
you can get away actually with having a
graph that's not vertex transitive
but actually is quasi vertex transitive
which means that the you know
effectively the number of
that you don't have the same that not
all vertices have the same neighborhood
structure
but you have a finite number of
neighborhood of different neighborhood
structures uh
you know into which every vertex in the
graph can be kind of can be put into one
of those different uh
different families of neighborhood
structures so these are examples of
quasi
you know there's like tetrahedral graphs
dodecahedral graphs buckyball graphs
these are all examples of kind of
quasi-vertex transitive graphs that
would also be
you know good candidates for a possible
fixed dimensional base space
with within which or with respect to
which to quantify uh global dimension
change
okay so here are some examples let me
that was that was all a bit abstract let
me give some some specific examples so
so
these are cayley graphs for the uh for
the free group on it on two generators
obviously these are these are infinite
things in general
because that's that's a uh although it's
a finitely presented group it's a
it's a group with it's a finally
presented group with an infinite
calligraph
um but uh so so this you can think of as
being like a beta lattice
and then these are examples of calorie
graphs for symmetric groups so
effectively what we're doing is the only
difference between these
and those is that because these are free
groups these don't have any
you know they're just generators there
are no relations between the elements
these have both generators and
non-trivial relations which is why you
get effective merging
of vertices in the kelly graph so those
are symmetric groups these are examples
for alternating groups
um this is a way in which you can you
know again
purely with respect to geometric group
theory consider something consider
a combinatorial structure that has a
well-defined infinite limit as some
continuous thing
so this is a sequence of calligraphs
whose whose limit uh in the infinite
case is known to be the heisenberg group
which is of course a sort of which is a
group you would conventionally represent
in terms of continuously varying
quantities
but it's something it's nevertheless its
presentation is something you can build
up
as an infinite limit of combinatorial
presentations
uh which is which is kind of amusing
okay
um so like i said we don't uh we're
hoping hope maybe some people
uh the summer school may be able to
figure out in more detail than i
understand
um exactly how we can go about
developing a general theory of
general relativity for varying
dimensional manifolds uh
and and and importing techniques for
differential geometry and algebraic
topology
over to the case of of sort of manifolds
where you don't have uh
you know connected components that have
fixed dimension but uh
um so we we don't know the correct way
to analyze that
but just because we don't have the
correct way to analyze it doesn't mean
we can't do computer experiments and so
that's that's kind of something we've
done
and it turns out you know there's
there's a fairly general class of these
systems
that have this rather nice property that
their effective global dimension
uh changes over time and that's amusing
because we think it has a
that has a bunch of implications for
early universe cosmology
so um the way that basically works is if
you imagine
okay so in order to get the einstein
equations one thing we had to do was to
assume
that the causal network that we get out
and the hyper graphs we get out you know
have have
ultimately finite dimensions so uh in
other words what that means is
if you start out with a hypergraph or a
causal network that's very very densely
connected that exists in effectively
infinite dimensions
um then in order for it to satisfy the
einstein field equations
it has to converge down to something
that's finite dimensional so in other
words it has to go from something that's
very densely connected
and through the dynamical procedure that
is the application of the updating
events
it has to converge down to something
that's sparsely connected and so
you can think about that as being like
you know the early universe is extremely
causally connected and then becomes more
sparsely causally connected as
the universe evolves and so that's
immediately interesting because
obviously
increased causal connectivity of the
early universe is kind of the main
reason why people considered
why people like allen gooth and andre
linde considered inflationary models of
cosmology back in the 1980s
so um and so it turns out that actually
we can reproduce
uh basically all of the all the kind of
conformal consequences of space-time
for things like inflationary models of
cosmology without having to postulate
inflation without having to postulate
something like an inflaton field
and the way we can do it is by this
process of starting out with hypographs
that are effectively infinite
dimensional and that converge down to
hypergraphs that are finite dimensional
because if you have a hypergraph that's
arbitrarily well connected that's
arbitrarily well causally connected
you can think about that as being like a
universe where the effective speed of
light is is very very high or even
infinite right because you're basically
saying
information can propagate through the
hypergraph much faster because of the
increased connectivity than it otherwise
would have been able to
so we can model this in a very toy case
you could model this as being like
it's a universe where uh where the speed
of light is just a scalar field
um and and uh we we could consider a
scalar field that's kind of continuously
varying but it's actually even easier to
consider a scalar field
where there's just a discontinuity given
by some some heavy side
step function which i'll call theta so
there's effectively some phase
transition that happens in the other
universe where we go from some
some universe where the speed of light
is the effective speed of light is
really high
to a universe where the effective speed
of light is comparatively low uh
where it has effectively its present
value um
so then you can ask okay if that happens
what would that look like well we can
write down
if we take the flrw metric that is the
the freedom and matria
robertson walker metric for the for an
expanding universe that's the sort of
the most general
uh homogeneous and isotropic spacetime
line elements that exists in general
relativity it's the basis
uh it's the sort of basic metric one
considers in in sort of
in things like lambda cem cosmology
and so then if we introduce this this
phase transition in c
governed by that so this is where this
phase transition takes place at some
point tc
then now this flrw metric essentially
factorizes into a pre-phase transition
and a post-phase transition metric
so we have this byte we have this
biometric form uh so this is the
essentially the pre-phase transition
metric and this is the post-phase
transition metric
so what we end up with are two separate
light cones for the universe
uh and their and their size is governed
by some dimensional ratio
which we'll call gamma um and then
the reason why that's interesting is
because now if we compute the horizon
scale
we can see that the horizon scale you
know as long as the as long as the
initial value of the speed of light c
naught is is sufficiently large compared
to the final value
cm then we can determine that the the
proper horizon scale is much larger than
it would have been
if the if the effective speed of light
had been constant and so so in
particular
one obtains uh one of the in the limit
as gamma goes to infinity the proper
horizon becomes arbitrarily large
and so we we can deduce that that sort
of everything ex
all all points of space must exist in
the forward like cone of the initial
singularity so in other words everything
is causally connected
and therefore in particular it's much
the the region of causal connectivity
is is much larger than the region from
which we are currently receiving photons
from cosmic microwave background
and so so the fact that we see effective
isotropy and homogeneity
in in horizon is unsurprising if this if
such a phase transition occurred
so it it does constitute a valid
solution to the horizon problem
uh also excitingly it constitutes a
valid solution to the flatness problem
because if we take the standard friedman
equation the the you know the the
equation that describes
an expanding universe with with scale
parameter a
uh and where the hubble parameter h is
effectively uh governing the
the rate of change of that scale
parameter then as long as we assume
there's no cosmological constant
uh we can write is that we can
reformulate the sort of the effective
rate of exp
the ratio of the effective speed of
light to the effective change in the
in in the uh to the effective rate of
expansion in terms of this parameter
epsilon
which is the so that's the parameter
that you would sort of probe when
talking about the numbers of e folds
of inflation and so on that that one
would see
in the early universe then in terms of
that parameter you you can write you can
construct this
this other quantity omega um and then
which again which is also a quantity
that people sort of investigate in terms
of expansion rates of
of the early universe and you can just
you can just examine
what is the rate of change of epsilon
and
so then again assuming a universe which
is radiation dominated assuming that the
the the cosmological equation of state
that you know your p over row quantity
uh is is of the radiative form then what
you end up with is a cosmological
attractor solution
where the where the epsilon the number
of e folds is approximately zero
and that corresponds to a universe that
is approximately spatially flat
and so again as long as there's there's
an effective phase transition in the
speed of light
uh as long as the discrepancy between
the early time speed of light and the
late time speed of light is sufficiently
large
you end up with a universe that's
homogeneous and isotropic and which also
has approximate spatial flatness
and so you end up with something that's
kind of observationally
indistinguishable
from a universe that was generated by
inflationary cosmology without actually
having to postulate inflationary
cosmology which i think is really really
neat and again
uh i think uh i forget who's working on
this i think it's
daria right is possibly going to be
investigating
to see whether it's possible to find
examples of these hypograph systems
which uh in which one starts from you
know very
arbitrarily well connected hypographs
which then have a
have some phase transition in their
global dimension that cause them to
converge down and then you know the
really exciting thing would then be to
to see if we can define something like a
heat equation uh on on a hypergraph with
exhibiting this kind of global dimension
change um
and then determine and so effectively
you can you can simulate some coarse
approximations to the cmb
and then you could actually see
explicitly whether you end up with a cmb
that's that's roughly homogeneous and
isotropic
whether you get sort of initial density
perturbations like you'd predict in
inflation
uh those kinds of things so uh this is
an area that i'm personally really
excited about this this connection
between
uh global change and dimension of the
hypograph and apparent sort of
exponential expansion in the early
universe
and an apparent variation in this in the
value of the speed of light
um just one final note and then and then
we can move on to
quantum mechanics which is the thing
we're actually supposed to be discussing
here
but um so in retrospect
thinking about it like that it's not
entirely surprising that there should be
a connection between
uh the you know the number of dimensions
of the hypergraph and the effective rate
of expansion because that's actually
that's a property that you see already
in in ordinary general relativity in
ordinary
uh relativistic cosmology because if you
if you take the the friedman lamitra
robinson walker element uh there's
nothing even though it's conventionally
written in four dimensions
uh you know the the definition of the
euclidean metric extends to arbitrarily
many dimensions so there's nothing to
stop you from just writing it in an
n-dimensional form like this in terms of
in terms of the euclidean metric delta
ij
and so uh then what you can do is you
can you let if you say let's
assume a perfect relativistic fluid uh
where uh again
where you're essentially assuming a a
radiation um
a cosmological equation of state uh that
obeys this
this conservation law so which is like
you know the higher dimensional analog
of mass conservation or energy density
conservation as i should say
um then what and you just substitute
that in to
a as the as the effective equation of
state for your
uh for you for your n-dimensional
universe what you end up with
is a reduced form of the einstein field
equations
uh with with this cosmological equation
of state
and then the actual and then if we and
then if we take the flw equations and
we solve the system of differential
equations for the scale parameter for
the parameter a that tells you
effectively the the length scale of the
universe
the expansion scale of the universe uh
you end up with something that can be
computed analytically and it has
this general form i i won't ask you to
prove it but it is
this is um you know this is a a
a computation that you can in principle
do if you if you i i mean
if you want to try sticking this into
dissolve you're welcome to do it it will
give you the right answer but it's a
little bit ugly
um but anyway uh so what and what this
is telling you
is that there is an exponential
relationship between the effective
dimension of this of the space
and the and the perceived expansion rate
of the universe and
and of course as i say at least on a
phenomenological level that's exactly
what we see in these hypergraph models
and uh and i'm really looking forward to
getting kind of more uh more actual data
from these computer experiments to
confirm that this is actually true
so but you know at least to the
theoretical level this is very promising
because it means that this general
prediction
that you know global dimension change
implies effectively global uh variation
in the sp in the effective speed of
light
and that is related to uh you know to a
universe which has the same conformal
structure
as one that's exponentially expanding uh
you know as i say
the fact that that's a generic
prediction of our models and it turns
out it's a
it's something that exists in in
ordinary general relativity as well
uh that's something i think is really
quite exciting so i believe that's the
end of that of that particular thing
uh we could take a couple of minutes uh
if people want to take a break or people
want to ask questions before we move on
to
to quantum mechanics but was there i
know that there were a bunch of things
that we couldn't oh sorry
that's my spotify list um
zoom is not opening for me if i stop
sharing for a moment
um i know there are a bunch of questions
that came up this morning that people
might want to have answered if they if
they're still
interested but otherwise we can just
take a few minutes of break and then we
can move on to
the quantum mechanics stuff
john you you have unmuted yourself is
this
[Music]
um i had a quick question about this
sorry sorry something went wrong with my
audio i missed the first part of that
can you uh sorry just repeat
yeah um this is john i just had a quick
question um this
this dimensionality reduction is it
something that that is the discontinuous
that you would expect like a phase
transition or
or might it be sort of uh no
i i i would suspect it's continuous but
i don't
um i don't have the i don't have the
mathematical ability to analyze it in
the continuous case the the only the
only case where i was able
actually to prove anything is in the
case where you when we considered it to
be effectively
discontinuous like i say we're basically
bitten by the fact that no one has
developed a theory of differential
geometry
that works in varying dimensional spaces
um
that's something we're hoping people
will do but uh it's just that
you know the math doesn't exist yet um
the closest thing that
we have any any bearing on whether the
universe is open or closed or is it
uh that's an interesting question so um
and we don't know i mean
this is uh that's a that's a
sufficiently
the derivation of the of things like the
ionic equations and inflationary
cosmology
are sufficiently generic that we don't
you know that they're compatible with
the city universes anti-decentral
universes flat universes
um we don't yet have enough kind of
external data to know
what the what the what the eschatology
is so to speak what you know what what
the final
what the final geometry will look like
and i believe there's a project
oh gosh i forget who we assigned it to
now if if the person we assigned it to
is in the room please speak up
there is we assigned a project yesterday
that was about looking at
um pairs of hypergraph rules where one
grows the universe one contracts the
universe and seeing whether you end up
with
is you know seeing what the final what
the final stage is
who who ended up with that project i i
will remember in a minute
i think it was sam
was it sam is sam in the meeting no he's
not
maybe not okay that was the there there
there is a project this year there is at
least one project probably multiple in
the end
uh that we'll be investigating that so
that yeah um but that's a good question
we don't yet know
i should say by the way on the varying
dimension thing that the closest
uh sort of field that i've been able to
find the to the
the field that i've i found that has
come closest to addressing that question
is this thing called scale relativity
which are a bunch of people who try to
it seemed to be popular a few years ago
and no one seems to have published
anything on it since
but where they were trying to
effectively generalize general
relativity to the case where you have
manifolds where
um in addition to
lorenz invariants you also have
effectively scale invariants
and one of the interesting things about
that is
uh if you have scale invariants then
that gives you a way of kind of defining
einstein equations over fractal
manifolds whatever fractal manifold is
um and that seems like something would
be potentially very relevant
but as far as i can tell in the
literature i've seen the scale
relativity people
haven't actually succeeded in that goal
um they kind of they tried and
it doesn't seem to have gone anywhere
but maybe i'm wrong maybe i just missed
something but i couldn't
i couldn't find anything
did anyone else want to want to ask
anything oh
just have a very basic question about
the variable speed of light so
fascinating idea it definitely goes
against sort of historic precedent for
the constancy of the speed of light
i'm just going to give you a snapshot of
since you're in a position i'm not in to
see sort of across the
field how well is this received right
now or is this still going to be a bone
of contention so to speak
so with respect to the variable speed of
light in particular
yeah okay this is a this is a really
good question so and and the thing to
say about that is actually
this is not the first model that has
implied the variable speed of light that
in fact there's the whole field of vsl
cosmology variable speed of light
cosmology that has investigated this
and there are people like pettit and old
breath and moffat
and a bunch of others who've developed
models of variable speed of light
cosmology
and so so this idea that you could use a
variable speed of light
as a way of of of solving the horizon
and flatness problems
that's not a that's not a new idea for
this project
what um what this project kind of what
this model gives you
is actually a dynamics that explains why
the speed of light is varying right
it's it's saying that because the
hypergraph is starting off as very high
dimensional and converging down to
something low dimensional
one one naturally ends up with a
universe where the effect the maximum
rate of information propagation reduces
and so it kind of explains why a vsl
cosmology might be true
um so that that's the first thing i
would want to say about that but then so
you ask
you know how does how has this been
received vsl cosmology cosmologies i
think are
they're treated as being fringe but
respectable would be
would be my my basic assessment i i'm
not an expert in that particular area i
find i think vsr cosmologies are cool
uh i don't think anyone thinks that
they're cranks uh but it's also not oh
no it's not as mainstream as inflation
but then inflation is not a particularly
well developed theory in my opinion
either
um so i i think there's no there's no
reason to believe it's obviously wrong
it implies some some some funky stuff so
if
you have um if you have a speed of light
that's allowed to vary
not just in the early universe but over
the whole universe um then that implies
various things about you know variation
in the fine structure constant
and that and then that does lead you
into some issues about that i think
there are sort of
there are various astrophysical
experiments that have been done about
looking at the
about the fine structure of silicon and
things that have been
observed in in spectra from from uh
supernovae and things
uh that sort of put bounds on the degree
to which
uh the fine structure constant could
have varied in the course of our
universe i don't know very much about
those experiments other than the fact
that they indicate that the fine
structure constant probably hasn't
changed
and so that means that if there is a
variable speed of light
a it doesn't change the fine structure
constant which would be a bit weird or b
if it does change the fine structure
constant then it must have happened you
know all the variation
all the measurable variation in the
speed of light must have happened really
really early
you know before before things like stars
and so on
with spectra that we can observe
actually had time to form
um but uh yeah that's a it's a super
interesting question
i i i'm not an observational cosmologist
so i don't know
um i don't really know the answer but
that's uh yeah something we would be
really keen to figure out
oh that's terrific thanks a lot that's
great yeah no my pleasure
john i had a question if there's still
time yeah yeah absolutely
i i want to take a break for a few
minutes yeah go on
uh so so if this
kind of phase transition uh or
transition between dimensions is
happening when there's already a
continuous geometric
interpretation of the graph my
assumption is that
if you really looked at a continuous
model where you had all the consistency
what you would end up with is basically
an effective in photon field
describing this and your your output
would be you would get all the
parameters of the
effective lagrange infest uh inflicton
field
for any of your given update rule which
would be great um i mean that i think is
a sense in which
inflation is not well developed is in a
real good reason to expect any
particular
inflation while by morning if that is
the setup you have in mind or if you
have in mind
uh this situation where you don't have
your con you are resolving these
problems before you have your continuous
limit
that's a really really awesome question
and so i i have neither
scenario in mind in the sense that i i
obviously we don't know
um it's it's a really good question of
whether whether this
if there if there were a rapid phase
transition in the effective dimension of
the universe
whether it occurred at a time scale
where discreteness was still important
that's a super interesting question
that's one of the reasons actually why
we put in i think one of the
one of the projects on the list was
about looking at
the kind of the network structure of the
cosmic web
it's a slightly crazy idea for a project
but one of the reasons why we thought
that would be interesting to investigate
is that if if the phase transition
occurred at
a time scale where you didn't have a
continuous geometry and where
discreteness was still relevant
one might expect to see the actual
network structure of the hypergraph
essentially imprinted on the large-scale
structure of the universe potentially in
something like the cosmic web
like i say it sounds a bit nuts i'm not
entirely sure if it's actually true but
i thought
you know it's something that might be
interesting to investigate uh but yeah
so to answer your question
we don't know um and uh i agree with you
that
it seems overwhelmingly likely that what
you would end up with
uh if you actually if you do have a
continuous geometry is something like an
influence you know
something like a slow role in photon
potential um that you know
i i completely agree that probably is
the most most uh plausible scenario and
i also agree that
you know the sense in which i think in
inflationary theory is not well
developed is
you know the relativistic side the
cosmological side is perfectly well
developed
but the actual detailed particle physics
of why
why is there an infant on how does it
couple to other quantum fields and
things
again not being a particle physicist i i
can't speak too authoritative
authoritatively about that but my
understanding is that's still very much
an open question
um and potentially if if global
dimension change at a continuous scale
does produce an effective in photon
it has a way of answering it which i
think is kind of cool
thanks i hope that makes sense i is i
did i say anything obviously false
that was great yeah that was resolved
thank you
okay cool
uh all right
okay uh well i guess if if no one else
wanted to ask anything immediately
obviously we have we have a discussion
session and things after after this and
i'm going to try and
end this early so we can all take a
break for half an hour or longer
before that before that all starts but
since we have
since we have everyone here let's let's
make a start on talking a little bit
about quantum mechanics
um so
okay so here's the here's the big
picture
so far everything we've been discussing
has ignored multi-way systems we started
by by saying
you know the the evolution of this of
one of these buffer model systems
is non-deterministic because there are
generally many different updating orders
there are generally
many different places where rules can
get applied and different
different updating orders will yield to
different it will yield different
non-isomorphic spatial hypographs and
hence different evolution histories for
the universe
but then we said we're going to impose
this condition which is causing the
variance
which is which is kind of our excuse for
not having to think about multi-way
systems because it's what guarantees
that even independent of which updating
order you choose the causal network you
get out
is always the same up to isomorphism but
now
what i want to do in order to address
this the question of how you know what
how can this model relate to quantum
mechanics is go back to that an
initial assumption what if instead
instead of having to get rid of
multi-way systems
what if we say that multi-wave systems
are actually really fundamental
so um this is the multi this is
everyone's favorite multi-way system
that we started with i think in the in
the first lecture
and then we said you know let's assume
that all of the all the branch pairs
converge that one has effective global
confluence
and moreover that one has causal
invariance and we'll use that to derive
special relativity
and general relativity but one thing
that i mean i'm sure that will
have occurred to many of you is that
these multi-way systems these
multi-evolution graphs
are very path integral like right in in
an ordinary path integral
you say that the the the trajectory of a
quantum system is described by a sum
over all possible trajectories a
functional integral of all possible
trajectories
where each trajectory is rated it is
weighted by a quantum amplitude
uh or or more precisely by this phase
term e to the is
uh sx dot which is which is the the the
action in terms of the the sort of
in terms of the the lagrangian density
and so this gives you a way given the
given the overall wave function
it gives you uh so given the initial
value of the wavefunction gives you a
way of computing the overall wave
function for any future time
and so this this notion of taking
functional integrals over all possible
trajectories
is very much like this it does seem very
much like the continuum analog of a
multi-wave evolution graph
and so again just as the actual path
integral is not you know
we don't really know how to make the
path integral mathematically rigorous in
ordinary quantum field theory because we
don't know how to how to define
integration measures over sort of
over infinite dimensional function
spaces um in much the same way we don't
know how to make this correspondence
with the path integral
fully mathematically rigorous but um i
want to kind of give you some
indications of
how that correspondence might work and
and why we think it actually is true and
i'm going to present some some sort of
some heuristic mathematical evidence
for for why why that might actually be
the case and what the translation
between
the path integral formulation of quantum
mechanics and the the multi-way system
sort of formulation of wolfer model
evolution might actually be
so the basic idea is if we have a
multi-way system there is a natural
measure that gets defined on it there is
a natural uh
and that measure is essentially in terms
of pathways so given a particular state
in the multi-way evolution graph
we can ask how many incoming paths to
that state yields that particular state
how many distinct ways were there of
achieving that particular state
that gives us a natural way of weighting
the vertices in the multi-evolution
graph
and and hence gives us a measure over
which we can integrate if we
if we take a sensible continuum limit of
the multi-wave system and so so the
again the the conjecture that i kind of
want to suggestively place in your minds
is that that is like the dx integration
measure that that appears in the
in in the standard sort of quantum field
theoretic uh formulation of the path
integral okay
um so now let me let me build up some
terminology from mathematical logic
that's going to help us to make the
correspondence between multi-systems and
ordinary and things you
you would think about in ordinary
quantum mechanics so
the first is this notion of a critical
pair uh so a critical pair loosely
speaking is
you know if okay if you if you have um
if you have an abstract term rewriting
system if you if you have a system where
uh all of you you have an abstract
rewriting system where every element is
a term
every element is an expression that
contains nested sub-expressions like in
the case of a hypergraph
then you can define this notion of a
critical pair which is like the minimal
notion of an ambiguity in terms of the
application of the term rewrite so it's
saying that effectively
your your two rewrite operations can can
uh overlap with each other that there's
a that there's a common sub expression
to both
that that is unifiable with either the
same rule or
the same rule being applied in two
different places or with uh
uh or with uh different rules uh in in
some
finite rewrite system um and so when
that happens you get this thing called a
critical pair so a critical pair is the
statement of the ambiguity
so in the context of our uh of our
multi-way systems
a critical pair corresponds to an
elementary bifurcation in the multi-wave
system it's an indication that
either there was the same updating event
that could get applied in two different
places
or there were two different updating
events that could get applied and that
they yield a different
uh non-isomorphic state so
non-isomorphic spatial hypographs in the
actual hypograph case
or non-equivalent strings in the case of
in this sort of string
toy model so for instance
if you had if you have a particular term
rewriting system that that maps you know
f of g of x y comma z onto g of x z and
g of x y goes to x then this system has
one
non-trivial critical pair associated
with it because both of these elements
can be derived from a common sub
expression f of g x comma z
by applying a single rewrite step you
can also consider the case of of trivial
critical pairs
where there are two different rules that
can get applied or the same rule could
get applied in two different ways
but they and they yield the same common
expression so
uh in the multi-way system that would be
a pair of evolution edges but where they
both
yield at the same state and so in the
multi-wave system
we happen you know in the standard way
we set these up uh
you know states corresponding to trivial
critical pairs get automatically merged
and states corresponding to non
non-trivial critical pairs
uh are kept to the separate but um there
there's a
as i'll explain in the talk i'm going to
give on thursday i'll show you actually
how to use the multi-system code
and in particular by by enabling by
including state ids or by requesting the
unmerged evolution graph
you can consider not not just the
non-trivial critical pairs but also the
trivial ones as well
okay so then if there is a if there is a
critical pair if there is
an elementary bifurcation in one of
these multi-wave systems you can then
ask the question of does that does that
critical
pair converge does it does it reconverge
on do the two elements of that
bifurcation eventually reconverge on
some common state
now of course that's exactly the same
question that we considered back when we
were thinking about special relativity
for as a means of defining global
confluence which
as i mentioned is is intimately related
to to the causal invariance property
so effectively you can think of a a
strengthened version of global
confluence
is is exactly the statement that every
critical pair is is
sorry no not a strength a weakened
version
of global confluence which is which is
local confluence
is exactly the statement that every uh
every non-trivial critical pair
is forced to converge so in other words
we can say
that if we have a critical pair x y in
some rewrite system then it's convergent
if there's some common element z
such that there's a rewrite sequence a
finite rewrite sequence mapping x to z
and a finite rewrite sequence mapping y
to z
now i mentioned that this this local
confluence property this this property
that critical pairs are convergent
um it is is a is a weaker version of
of ordinary global confluence but there
exist cases in which it's actually
equivalent to global confluence
and and those cases are exactly the
cases where the rewrite system
terminates
where uh instead of the instead of the
multi-wave evolution graph kind of
uh extending off infinitely everything
just converges down
to some common state and and so that
would correspond to a rewrite system
that we would describe as strongly
normalizing
and and so in the case of a strongly
normalizing rewrite system
uh that it turns out that weak
confluence and global confluence
are exactly the same um so i i'll
discuss it in slightly more
formal detail what that means and how we
derive that in just a minute but
um you know so the basic idea is if we
want to know local confluence
it's really easy we just compute all the
critical pairs all of the elementary
branchings in the multi-way system
and we see whether they converge now i
say it's easy it's conceptually easy
algorithmically it's really difficult
because actually this is an undecidable
problem
because the because it's it's equivalent
to solving the word problem for
financially present
for finitely presented groups and we
know that that that problem is
undecidable
um but uh what you know
this gives us a immediately gives us a
sort of a fairly quick way of
determining
possible causal non-invariant rules
because if we if we can find a critical
pair
and we can show that it doesn't converge
then we know that the system is not
locally confluent
which means that it's not globally
confluent and therefore by extension we
know that it can't be causal and variant
um and so in the same way as uh you know
you can think of disconnected regions in
the causal network as being separated by
something like an event horizon
uh that can again the suggestive
conjecture that i'm going to make to you
now
and hopefully be able to back up a
little bit later on is that if you
consider
multi-way branches that are disconnected
those can be those can be thought of as
being like super selection sectors in
some projective hilbert space so
obviously in ordinary quantum mechanics
once you're in a particular super
selection sector
you know you you it's effectively like
you can't get out
that's kind of you know our conjecture
is that's the multi-way analog
of causal disconnection uh due to the
presence of an event horizon
okay so let me describe in a bit more
detail what i meant by this distinction
between local and global confluence and
this notion of strong normalization
so we can say that an object is reduced
to some normal form
if it's no longer possible to rewrite it
any further if it doesn't exist some
some element that is the successor
element of that state
so if it were the case that we reached
some point in the multi-way system where
there was just some state and we
couldn't go any further there was no
more rewrite we could apply to it
we would say that that element was a
normal form that that state was a normal
form
so then we can we can describe a
multi-way system or an abstract rewrite
system
as being weakly normalizing if every
finite rewrite sequence
uh sorry sorry let me say that again it
we can describe it as being weakly
normalizing if there exists some finite
rewrite sequence
and we can describe it as strongly
normalizing if every finite rewrite
sequence
terminates at some normal form so a
weakly normalizing multi-way system
would be one in which
every branch of the multi-way system you
know independent of which state you get
to
there is some branch of the multi-wave
system which allows you to reach a
normal form
on the other hand strong normalization
which says that every finite rewrite
sequence terminates in a normal form
would correspond to the statement that
it's not that you can find a branch that
terminates
it's that every branch is guaranteed to
terminate
and like i say the reason why that's
kind of important is because
uh if if the system is is uh weakly
normalizing
there's this result called newman's
lemma or the uh sorry if it's weakly
confluent
and strongly normalizing then there's
there's this result called newman's
lemma
or the diamond lemma that says that
global confluence uh is equivalent to
local confluence in that particular case
so in other words as long as we have a
multi-way system that that eventually
terminates at some common state
then we then we know that branch pair
convergence critical pair convergence
is both a necessary and sufficient
condition for guaranteeing causal
invariance
so actually doing causal and variance
testing for multi-way systems where
every branch eventually terminates at
some normal form state
that's for those systems you know
algorithmically determining causal
invariance is really really easy
but of course the you know the systems
we're actually interested in are the
ones where
the multi-wave system doesn't terminate
and where everything goes on in you know
add infinitum and then uh then we don't
then newman's number no longer applies
and you know we there's no longer any
decidable uh finite process
for determining causal invariants one of
the things we want to investigate
uh but we haven't investigated yet and
as far as we know no one in theoretical
computer science has investigated it yet
is the question of whether there is some
sort of probabilistic analog of newman's
lemma that also applies for rewrite
sequence for rewrite systems that are
not strongly normalizing
so so that you know if you know that
some fraction of of critical pairs
necessarily converge
does that give you some bound on on how
you know how likely the system is
is to be uh to be globally confident or
or even locally confluent
um we don't even uh as far as i know
there isn't even a sensible way of
formulating that question
yet but it's one that we'd really like
to like know the answer to
um okay so uh in the in the
so although critical pairs is the sort
of is the terminology to get used in
mathematical logic
because of because these things are
associated with branchings
in the multi-way evolution graph we
think critical pairs is actually a
little bit too obscure as a piece of
terminology so we've started calling
them branch pairs and we're trying to
kind of we're trying to make this
terminology
catch on somehow in the in the world of
abstract rewrite systems
um so if we consider uh the evolution of
the system which i think is
uh which i think corresponds to uh wait
no i don't have a picture of it maybe i
have a picture of it later on
um but if we consider a hypergraph
system like like this one here we can
therefore compute what are its branch
pairs what are the what are the
elementary
bifurcations that exist in the
multi-wave system what are the
ambiguities
in the up the elementary ambiguities in
the updating order so in this case
there are 14 kind of main main branch
pairs that appear
when you when you first evolve the
system but it turns out
after those 14 branch pairs have
appeared if you go another time step six
of them
resolve six of them resolve within a
single step these particular sets
if we go another time step eight of them
resolve and so we can determine this was
assist you know assuming that this was a
a terminating rewrite system assuming
that it was strongly normalizing
uh this would guarantee that this was a
this has to be a causal invariant
uh system because every branch pair
converged within two update steps
so uh it's it's not as causal variant as
a system where everything terminated
with
everything converged within a single
rewrite step uh but it's still
nevertheless causing various it's still
locally confluent and hence globally
confluent
and therefore and moreover because it's
because it's strongly normalizing
it's therefore also causing the variant
uh this is a more complicated example of
that
uh that illustrates why causal
invariance testing is so difficult to do
so if we consider so this slightly
modified uh
hypograph rewrite system this time it
produces 58 branch pairs
after after a certain amount of
evolution if we go a single time step
onwards
uh then six of them happen to resolve
but if we go a further time step
none of them resolve none of the
remaining ones resolve if we go another
time step again none of them resolve
and so uh of course in principle we have
to go to infinitely many time steps in
order to know for certain
that these were not going to resolve but
we can start to build up kind of
heuristic evidence that in fact the
system
is probably not causal invariant but
this is as i say this is an undecidable
problem
you know we kind of we can't know in
general
okay so the point
that let me try and let me try and
motivate my my
reason for introducing all of this we've
already established that causal
invariance is what we need in order to
get special relativity and general
relativity in the continuum limit
but we also we've also established that
kind of having non-causal invariants
having having bifurcations in the
multi-wave system that don't necessarily
immediately reconverge is appears to be
necessary for getting at least some
aspects of quantum mechanics um and so
for a long time that was kind of
that was a major concern you know how
you can make the the necessary call
the necessary calls and variants of
special relativity and general
relativity
compatible with the apparently necessary
non-causal invariants of quantum
mechanics
so then about a year ago i made a
conjecture that
um that it has to do with this this
concept called cliff bendex completion
which is a pretty abstract idea that
comes from automated theorem proving
um but basically what it allows you to
do is to start from a system
from a rewrite system that is not
globally confluent that doesn't satisfy
causal and variance
and by applying effective update rules
that
cause critical pairs to converge that
forced convergences between branch pairs
it allows you to end up with a rewrite
system that is still you know
after a certain number of applications
appear that still appears to be globally
confluent
so i'm going to just quickly run you
through roughly how that works i think i
mean
understanding the the algorithmic
intricacies of the mathematics procedure
is probably not required
in order for you to understand how
quantum mechanics works in these models
but the basic idea is we're given a
strongly normalizing rewrite system that
is not globally complement
what we want to do is to construct a new
rewrite system that is that is globally
complement
but which preserves kind of the large
scale structure of the original rewrite
system
where in this case large scale structure
refers to this to what's called
deductive closure so the deductive
closure
um if the if the rewrite relations are
symmetric so everything is just an
equivalence relation
the deductive closure is essentially the
the it's the set of equalities that you
could prove
uh using some finite with some finite
proof method
given the original set of of
equivalences so what you're trying to
find is a rewrite system that preserves
the deductive closure
but which introduces global confluence
um
and so as i say you're considering
symmetric rewrite relations where x goes
to y y goes to x for all x and y
and uh and so so what kinetics
completion does
is it computes the critical pairs of
this rewrite system
and then it imposes new equivalences
between between those objects
that force those pairs to converge and
then once those pairs
once you've converged enough of them
once you've forced enough of these
branch but these elementary branch pairs
to converge
you're guaranteed that you have global
confluence and and so then
uh one thing that we had to do in order
to to make this work in our case is
generalize it for the case of
of of potentially asymmetric relations
because of course our hypergraph rules
are not necessarily symmetrical in time
so
uh so to do that it actually turns out
it's not it's not particularly difficult
uh you can you know you just consider uh
the binary relation that is the rewrite
closure
of the abstract rewrite system so it's
the smallest uh rerelation that contains
the the the set of uh of rewrite rules
and then you can you can construct its
converse closure which is the set
which is effectively the closure of its
conv that's the closure of its converse
relation
and that gives you a way of simulating
an a symmetric rewrite system from
within an asymmetric one and then you
can ask about the deductive closure
with respect to the converse closure of
of that rewrite system
and so so then uh if you imagine okay
in the symmetrical case if i let me just
quickly walk you through an example
if you consider this symmetrical case um
then
th these are rewrite relations that
happen to correspond to axioms of
standard group theory the axiom of
identity
uh left identity left inverse and
associativity respectively
then it's possible to prove group
theoretically that this theorem holds
that
these these two terms are equal are
equivalent with respect to the
reflective transitive closure
of this uh of this equivalence relation
and the way you can do that
is by determining that there exists a
finite a finite deduction chain
that leads from the left-hand side to
the right-hand side and and so that that
implies that this
uh this equivalence is an element of the
deductive closure of e
even though it isn't an element of e
itself and we can do exactly and again
using this generalized method we can do
exactly the same argument and apply it
to the case of the asymmetric
relations as well so uh if instead of
having uh bidirectional rules for the
group theory if we just had single
directional rewrite rules for group
theory
then this although this theorem would be
an element of the deductive closure
because there exists a
a a a a a unidirectional rewrite chain
that leads
the results that allows you to join the
left-hand side
to the right-hand side on the other hand
this
this original theorem that we proved in
the symmetrical case
wouldn't hold because now uh because
these rules are unidirectional there
isn't a way to apply a right to left
variant of the associativity rule which
is what you would need to do in order to
in order to reduce the left and right
hand sides onto some common normal form
okay like i said that was all a little
bit abstract so that's that's giving you
at least a sort of
a little bit of background about what
this what this bendix completion
procedure is and why it's used in
mathematical logic
but how can we use it in one of our
multi-way systems so uh here's here's a
really simple example of that
so here is an example of a system that
terminates at some normal form
it's it's it's weakly normalizing
because there are normal forms
for any state there is a branch you can
reach which which for which that
for which that branch terminates some
normal form so you can see here here's
an elementary example
because there's no rule uh in the system
that has b
on the left hand side once we obtain a b
here there's no there's no more update
that can get applied here so this is
this is an example of a normalization
point a point where we've achieved a
normal form in the multi-way system and
therefore because we've achieved a
normal form on one branch
we know that the system can't be causal
invariant because because this this is
an elementary branch pair an elementary
critical pair
which definitely doesn't reconverge and
so
the question is how so this is like this
this is something which is non-causal
variant which is fun which is a
fundamentally kind of quantum mechanical
uh multi-way system so then the question
is how can we make this
this compatible with with special
relativity and general relativity which
require causal invariance
so essentially my the the big picture
sort of philosophical idea
uh that i had was maybe the reason why
quantum gravity is hard
is precisely because quantum mechanics
requires confluence
and sort of a relative quantum mechanics
requires non-confluence
and relativity requires confluence and
so you have to have some way of bridging
the gap between the two
and so it turns out clinics completion
gives you a way to do that
and uh and so my conjecture was that
this would be related to the process of
quantum measurement and that's now
become kind of the the
our interpretation for how measurement
how the measurement process works within
the context of these willful model
systems
so i'd now like to kind of quickly walk
you through how how that goes
so if we add a completion rule that
allows you to link
b to a to a a then that gives you a way
of
of just immediately resolving this
branch pair so if we do that what we end
up with
is this thing here where now you can see
all of these elementary branch pairs
that were not reconverging because they
terminated in normal forms
now they're able to converge because now
there's a way to get from the estate to
that state that didn't exist before
we haven't changed the rewrite closure
we haven't changed the deductive closure
of the system
it's still you know the the the the same
set of the same set of rewrite uh
relations that exist between elements
also exist in the completed version
it's just that now it's possible to to
to prove global confluence
where we couldn't prove it before so my
my kind of hypothesis was
that maybe this is what an observer is
doing that the observer is some extended
object in the multi-way system some
extended object in the multi-way
evolution graph
they're seeing a the the underlying uh
sort of
system the rewrite system for the
universe is non-causal and variant it's
non-confluent
and therefore quantum mechanical and
what but what the observer is doing
is that is they are imposing a
completion procedure that allows them to
perceive the universe as being
relativistically invariant
even though the actual microstructure of
the universe might not be
and uh okay i'd like to make that
correspondence a bit more precise
so um one thing that's sorry
before i do that one thing that's worth
mentioning is so this was a case where
just
we there was a really simple completion
procedure that we could apply that
allowed everything that allowed all of
the branch pairs to converge within a
single step
but that's not generically going to be
the case that generically it could
require arbitrarily many steps
uh before one achieves causal invariance
even post completion so if we have a
string substitution system like this
this is one that is that is definitely
non-confluent it has a bunch of
a bunch of places where there are
critical pairs that definitely don't
reconverge i mean here's an example of
one because
you know bb is clearly a normal form
um but if we look at the relative rates
of branch pair
uh resolution and and non-resolution uh
we can see that even after adding
a a sort of minimal set of completion
rules that guarantees causal and
variance
the branch pair completion time can be
arbitrarily long so so you know
even in this relatively simple case um
we just you know we apply these this
particular pair of completion rules
we which we can prove are the minimal
set that that's that's needed to
guarantee global confluence
but uh even even after applying these
completion procedures
it can take an arbitrarily large number
of multi-way evolution steps before
things sort of converge down
to a common state so even post
completion
this is kind of this is still a
computationally expensive process
okay so like i say um how do we make a
correspondence between this and ordinary
quantum mechanics
so the idea is that the in the same way
as the
an observer in relativity is defining
space like hypersurfaces is defining a
foliation of the causal network
into space like hypersurfaces into sets
of events they can consider to be
simultaneous
the basic principle here is that in
quantum mechanics what the observer is
doing is they're
observing the multi-way evolution graph
and so what they're doing is they're
this by the they're foliating the
multi-way evolution graph
into a sequence of what we can call
branch-like hypersurfaces which are so
the collections of states that that the
observer is considering to be
simultaneous
but they're not events that are
simultaneous in the causal network
rather they are like microstates of the
universe that the observer is kind of
observing simultaneously
so this is an example again for the for
the toy case of a string substitution
system
this is an example of kind of a default
foliation for a multi-wave evolution
graph
so then the observer is seeing a
particular sequence of what we can call
branchial graphs of
which are our combinatorial way of
representing these branch-like
hypersurfaces
so these are the particular sets of
states that the observer is seeing
for each step of the in the evolution
history of the system so that you know
they start off by saying this pair of
states then this triple of states then
this
set of five states and so on and then
these pink edges
uh which were called which are the
branchial connections uh those are
determined by the
by the ancestry distance by the ancestry
structure of the multi-wave evolution
graph
so we're connecting in a particular
branchio graph
we connect a pair of states if they we
connect them directly
if they have an immediate common
ancestor in the multi-evolution graph
if they have a common ancestor that goes
back you know two an ancestor resistance
of two
then we then then in the branchial graph
they're going to be a graph distance of
two away from each other
um and again skipping ahead a little bit
uh the basic idea is that these are
the these branchial graphs can be
considered to be to be maps
of entanglements between between
elementary microstates of the universe
so the idea is that uh because the
observer rather than the observer seeing
a single
state of the universe at any one point
in time because they are
uh because the observer is defining this
branch like hypersurface where there are
actually multiple states of the universe
what they're seeing is effect can
effectively be thought of as like a
linear superposition of eigenstates
so where so each each uh element each uh
each node in the multi-way evolution
graph
is like an eigen state of the universe
and then when when the observer defines
this foliation they define that
hypersurface
that they're defining which collection
of eigenstates they're treating as being
in superposition
and then as i said at the beginning this
natural measure that we define on the
evolution graph in terms of path weights
in terms of just purely in terms of path
counting
then gives you a way of defining a
magnitude for the for the amplitude
with which which is which is this sort
of the the elementary weighting
of those elements in the superposition
and so again uh the conjecture that i'm
going to try and prove
well i'm going to prove a special case
of and i'm going to sort of try to
motivate
uh the conjecture in the more general
case but we don't have a proof in the
more general case
is that this the overall multi-evolution
graph limits to a projective hilbert
space
in in much the same way as the as the
limit as the causal network limits to
a sort of large-scale larency and
manifold and where the the sort of the
the natural metric on that on the
multi-evolution graph
is the standard fubini studio metric
tensor for projector hilbert space but
as i'll talk about that a bit more in a
little bit
okay so uh so as i say in ordinary
quantum mechanics we have this notion
that
that you know there's there's that each
quantum state is a linear superposition
of basis eigenstates
and so that idea is that each hype when
translated into this into this formalism
is that each hypersurface and the
branchial graph is some linear
superposition
of the individual eigenstates that
appear on that on
in that branch like hypersurface um and
so then
so then the the evolution of of this uh
of this time-ordered sequence of branch
like hypersurfaces
is therefore like the evolution of a
wave function of a normalized wave
function
where it's normalized in the sense that
we can we can we can sort of uh
we can set up the elementary pathways in
such a way that they always sum to one
and so then you can look at the the
weighted evolution of these branchial
graphs
of these branch-like hyper surfaces so
we can we can do something like
we we can take each vertex and we can
just render it bigger or smaller based
on the
the based on the path counting weight
based on how many elementary paths uh
uh how many distinct elementary paths
led into that particular vertex
that gives us a way of visualizing the
evolution of that superposition in time
and and seeing the the elementary
magnitudes of those amplitudes
um and so then uh what we're doing when
we perform a measurement
is we're we're taking this whole uh this
whole wave function and we want to
collapse it down to a single state we
want to collect
to a single eigen state with some
weighting and so my point
the point that i'm trying to make is
that's exactly what a multi-way uh what
what a what a completion procedure a
caliphate's completion procedure does
for these multi-way systems we saw
before that what we're really doing is
we're taking
some some big collection of of sort of
branch-like separated states
that correspond to these unresolved
branch pairs and by applying a multi-way
completion procedure by applying a
kinetics completion procedure
we're collapsing everything down to some
to some normalized state
that we can think of as being like the
collapsed eigen state
and so this is th this is the sense in
which the kinetics completion procedure
gives us an actualization of the
measurement process
um so what we're doing is say we're
taking this wave function we're taking
this branch like hypersurface or this
branchio graph and we're collapsing it
down to a single through a single ligand
state
and then the and and then obviously
because uh
so because as i say that the the our
the the magnitudes of the amplitude are
just the number of pathways and because
just on a just for sort of combinatorial
reasons we have
a we have an effective conservation of
those pathways we know that
uh if uh you know if if two paths led
into a particular state and it's not
uh it's not naughty and that state is
not a normal form then two parts have to
come out of it
or at least two parts have to come out
of it that's what effectively guarantees
that the born rule has to be satisfied
it's what guarantees that when we
collapse everything when we uh when we
collapse the the the particular branch
like hyperservice down to a single
eigenstate
that the pathway for uh for for for that
for the eigenstate that we we observe is
related to to the pathways of the
individual eigenstates that were in that
original superposition
by essentially the multi-way analog of
the of the borne rule so then once
and then just like in ordinary quantum
mechanics once you know once you've
reduced it down to that eigen state then
it's like the evolution is purely
classical
so that's the you know and so you know
in ordinary quantum mechanics we say
it's purely classical because now
your your a posteriori probabilities are
one
are given by some chronic delta function
and in the multi-way system we see the
same thing because once you've collapsed
everything down
so that it's trivially causally
invariant then there's only a single
effective evolution history there's only
a single effective thread of time in the
universe
okay so that's that's the kind of that's
the big picture idea of
of how how you can start from a from a
multi-way system that's non-causal
invariant and by applying a completion
procedure
you can collapse it down to something
that has effective causal and variance
and how that relates to a collapse of
into something like a collapse of the
wave function
in ordinary quantum mechanics but one
question that i think is very important
for you to ask if
i'm sure many of you have already been
asking is why would the observer cause a
completion procedure to occur
um you know why why does why does this
measurement a process actually
actually happen in the first place so um
i have a i have
two versions of this argument one of
which is is kind of very fuzzy and
heuristic and the other is a bit more
sort of mathematically solid but
let me give the fuzzy heuristic
explanation first and then maybe
tomorrow
uh depending on uh i i don't know how
long people want me to go on speaking
for here but
maybe tomorrow we can go over the kind
of the more mathematically detailed
version of this argument
but the basic idea is the okay the
observer is
the observer has two fundamental
properties in in in these systems
they are big and they are not confused
okay so so they're big in the sense that
they are extended objects in the multi
way evolution graph
and they are extended objects in the
spatial hypograph you know observers are
very big
compared with the underlying
combinatorial structure of the universe
and so um one implication that it has is
that just like in statistical mechanics
when you say that
you know where you you know if if two
particles are within some distance delta
each other in phase space if they if
their positions are momentum
within some distance delta then we say
that they are observationally equivalent
um and that's important for for
essentially reducing the number of
microstates in in thermodynamics down
from the infinite set that we
that we start with to the to the to the
the uncountable set that we start with
sorry to the countable set that you need
to fit to sort of plug into boltzmann's
entropy formula
the idea is that a similar kind of
course graining procedure is occurring
in the observer
that when you look at an individual
multi-way system each of these
bifurcations each of these elementary
critical pairs
that's a very very small deviation with
in multi-way space
and it's it's a sufficiently small
deviation relative to the macroscopic
observer
that we can that it's a reasonable
approximation to say that the observer
can't tell the difference
the these these microstates which only
differ at the level of a single updating
event
those those updating events are so
microscopic that the
the macroscopic observer cannot possibly
distinguish between those microphone
states
so so to the microscopic observer the
microstates appear to be equivalent
and so what what we can think of the one
one
physical way you can think about this
completion procedure
is that it's a coarse graining procedure
that the observer is performing so what
the observer is saying is
they're observing that you know the
evolution of this multi-way system with
respect to some universal time function
but then they're saying you know because
i'm because i'm a really big observer
relative to the underlying hypergraph
scale
i can't tell the difference between all
these different elements of the branch
pairs to me they all look the same
and so the observer is therefore
imposing an equivalence relation between
the elements on the branch like
hypersurface
which is another way of saying that
they're imposing a completion procedure
because they're
saying that they are imposing an
effective rule that says
aaa goes to aabb and aabb goes to aaa
because those two states are equivalent
with respect to that observer's own
reference frame
and so so then so the observer is
imposing this equivalence relation
between all of the elements on that
branch like hypersurface and so then
if you actually if you actualize that in
the context of one of these multi-wave
systems
that's exactly what a completion
procedure is and so this explains why if
you have an observer that's sufficiently
macroscopic
with respect to the underlying
hypergraph system such that they can't
distinguish between elementary
branch-like separations
because of the because of the nature of
the kinetics completion procedure
this is what guarantees that those
macroscopic observers can still
see uh large-scale causal invariants can
still see a definite
single evolution history for the
universe even if the underlying
microscopic rewrite
rules for the universe are not
themselves causally invariant
um okay so just before i uh
i i i i should stop talking pretty soon
because i know er everyone wants a break
at least uh
not least of all me but um just to to
give
some indication of you know again i i i
i
some elementary correspondence between
uh the formalism we've developed for
doing these completion procedures
in in that comes from mathematical logic
and standard formalism of quantum
mechanics
um rather excitingly not you know not
only do we get immediate actualizations
of concepts like
superpositions wave functions you know
collapsing to eigenstates measurement
processes and so on not only do we have
ways of
formulating that purely in terms of
rewrite theory we also
actually have a way of formulating
things like the uncertainty principle
and the canonical communication
relations
and so uh so the basic way that that
works is um
there's a notion there's an elementary
notion of computation that exists even
in abstract rewrite theory so you can
say if you have a pair of rewrite
systems
that are associated that have the same
common objects at a but have different
rewrite relations uh arrow one and arrow
two the sort of the
the so that you know the collection is
some some indexed union of sub relations
then we can say that those two rewrite
systems are commutative they commute
with each other
if for any elements such that for any
element x
such that x can be rewritten to y and x
can be rewritten to z
uh using the using the relations of of
um
r1 and r2 respectively then there exists
a common element w
such that y can be rewritten to w and z
can be rewritten to w
using the relations of r2 and r1
respectively so in other words
uh you know it's kind of it's exactly
what you'd think a commutation in a
rewrite system corresponds to if you
apply
if you apply this rewrite rule if you if
we apply rule one then rule two
then we get to the same result as if we
applied rule two than rule one uh
so that's that's the notion of kind of
of single step computation and then we
can also define a notion of multi-step
communication so if we define
an arbitrary rewrite sequence from rot
from one rewrite system
and we typ we apply an arbitrary rewrite
sequence from another rewrite system
if we then swap those around and we
apply a rewrite sequence from the second
and a rewrite sequence from the first
then we should get back to the same
result so this is so
um so commutation is is one case in
which you get kind of guaranteed
uh convergence of of branch pairs of
critical pairs um and so in other words
we we know that an abstract rewrite
system
is confluent it's globally confluent if
and only if it self commutes if and only
if
it commutes with itself that's that's a
pretty straightforward thing to see
a much more non-trivial thing to see
which is this thing called the
commutative union theorem
proved by hindley and rosen is actually
that there's a weak converse of that
that that in fact if uh if you have
commutativity
uh in in a family of arses then there's
a way of constructing a union of them
such that you have guaranteed confluence
in that union and so that gives us a way
of making a concrete connection between
commutativity of updating events in
these multi-way systems
and and causing the variance that you
know as a consequence of global
confluence
um and so so then a related result is is
a sufficient condition for
for commutativity of r1 and r2 is uh is
this sort of slightly strengthened
version
of the complements property and this is
essentially the the analog of the
statement that strong confluence is
is a is a sufficient condition for
global confluence but this time it's
saying that this sort of strong
commutativity property
is a sufficient condition for ordinary
commutativity
okay so um look actually
let me show you i mean if we if we just
quickly run through a picture of that to
make it
again a little bit less abstract you
know so if we're saying we can apply
this rule then this rule
uh you know we can apply rule one then
rule two we get to this point if we can
also apply rule two then rule one and
get to the same point
then that's you know that's an
elementary computation uh that that's a
statement that those two rules happen to
commute
and and every time you get an elementary
computation like that that corresponds
to a branch pair a critical pair that
converges within a single step
and so um conversely
if we have a non-causal variant system
if we have critical pairs that don't
converge
then they correspond to uh collections
of updating events that don't commute
that where applying r1 then r2 and r2
then r1 get you to different points in
the
in in the multi-evolution graph and
where in effect you know you
ev every every pair of points in in a
branch your graph that that are the
every pair of distinct points in a
branchial graph can therefore be thought
of as being a pair of points that got
produced
by some non-commuting sequence of
rewrite events that occurred in the
multi-wave evolution graph
why is that important well because it's
essential that's essentially the
statement of the uncertainty principle
but in the context of the multi-wave
evolution graph so if we think of the
rewrite relations as being the linear
operators that are acting on these
eigenstates as being
the linear operators acting on the on
the microstates that are the elementary
nodes in
in the multi-wave evolution graph then
uh
then then you can okay i'm going to
gloss over a slight subtlety here which
is
which is making the distinction between
uh updating events corresponding to
to sort of unitary evolution and
updating events corresponding to kind of
to hermitian measurement
um but then the idea is
if you if you have a re-relation that
corresponds to the to an observation
event
that corresponds to an event uh that
that measures some observable quantity a
then uh you know obviously in ordinary
quantum mechanics
uh the the the oh sorry
um in ordinary quantum mechanics you can
you can then if
for if you have a pair of uh of operator
of measurement operators that yield
uh measurements of two observable
quantities a and b and we
call those operators as a hat and b hat
we can then define their commutator
so what we're doing by considering by
considering computations of
abstract terminating systems is doing
the analogous thing but for the case of
these multi-way evolution graphs so
we're saying we can define
some additional operator that is the
commutator of these two elementary
rewrite relations in our system
and then we're effectively asking does a
hat b hat minus b hat a hat equals zero
in other words do you if you apply
a hat then b hat or and then apply b hat
then a hat do you get back to the same
state in the multi-way evolution graph
or do you get back to two different
states so that's so the question of
whether
whether you get uh whether you get
effective commutation between these
between these uh rewrite relations
is exactly the is exactly the question
of whether that whether that elementary
branch pair whether that
critical pair actually converged
um so then okay this is this is just
standard quantum mechanics that you
all know perfectly well you you can
treat the if a hat and b hat of
themselves linear operators then you can
treat the commutator as being a linear
operator
that just follows essentially from from
ordinary linearity
so okay this is this is uh probably the
picture that i should have put earlier
on
so this is the example of the same thing
occurring in a multi-wave evolution
graph so this is
this is like applying a hat than b-hat
this is like applying b-hat than a-hat
so this is the case where there is
perfect commutation where this branch
pair actually converged
um but then if you consider the case
where there isn't a perfect computation
then what you end up with are two
microstates that exist on the next
branch like hypersurface
two microstates that that still exist
even in in the
even in the next level in the branchial
graph um
so what we're really saying is if we
consider this these two updating events
as being like some some idealized
version of a measurement uh operation
what we're saying in the case where they
commute we're saying that if we measure
this quantity then this quant
if we measure quantity a then quantity b
or if we measured quantity b then
quantity a
we'd still get back we still get the
same the same net result
as the microstate of the universe would
be unchanged if they don't commute then
it's saying that somehow the time
ordering of the measurement operations
actually matters that it matters whether
you measure a first or b first
so in other words in the case where you
don't get commutation between these
elementary rewrite events
what we're saying is that there exists a
limit on the on the degree to which you
can prepare
an experiment which measures the
observables a
and b simultaneously and that's exactly
what the uncertainty principle
says uh you know what the uncertainty
principle says sort of
i say at a mathematical level is that uh
is that
observations that are made of
non-commuting observables necessarily
take place on different branches of
history with respect to some
some many worlds interpretation and
that's exactly what we're seeing here
when we have non-commuting
in the multi-way system what we're
seeing is that those those sets of
events necessarily take place on
different branches of the multi-way
system
and so then if and this is you know this
is a big if and it's one that i hope
it's a statement that i hope to justify
a bit more formally later on
if we consider the unit of distance on
one of these branchial graphs
or you know on one of these branch-like
hypersurfaces as being proportional to
h-bar or in particular
as being equal to i times h bar then
because
as i mentioned anytime you get
commutation you know
that means that you get convergent so
that means that that that you you had
two states in the branchial graph and
they converge down to one state
but if you don't get commutation that
means you now have you you started from
one state and you end up with two states
so you end up with a critical pair you
end up with a branch pair
so in other words you end up with a pair
of states that are separated by a single
edge
in the branchial graph so if the
elementary separation distance for each
branchial edge is i h bar
then that precisely corresponds to the
statement that that the the the the the
the
the commutation relation for that pair
of observables is canonical
and therefore we can think of the the
the associated observable quantities a
and b as being the fourier transform
duals of each other
so this is a here's an explicit example
of that here we can actually
this is a neat uh picture that stephen
produced actually of um
if you if we take a multi-way evolution
graph for an elementary string
system we can actually just map out what
are the what are the individual
communication relations we can see
uh by just coloring them separately each
of these diamonds that corresponds to a
communication
uh we we can cut we can color those and
we can see you know where where did we
get a branch pair where did it converge
and therefore
we can get a kind of a a visual uh
depiction of of the of the computational
relations for an elementary string
substitution system
um what else did i want to mention
this is a bunch of complicated stuff and
i'm not sure if i want to talk about it
right now
maybe i'll leave this for for a talk
either tomorrow or another time but so
um
one one other thing that i i kind of
wanted to talk about just really quickly
is uh
in terms of kind of building up this
dictionary between uh concepts in
mathematical logic related to rewrite
systems and multi-wave systems
and concepts that exist in ordinary
quantum mechanics you know we're we're
starting to do that and so
uh one of the nice things about that is
you know in addition to things to
elementary to rather trivial things like
the commutation relations and like
concepts of measurement operators and so
on we also have somewhat more
non-trivial things like in
like the concept of operator state
correspondence so in operators
in conformal field theory there's this
idea that you can you can biject between
the set of operators
and the set of states and you know that
idea is called the operator state
correspondence where the basic idea is
for for any state
you can consider constructing that state
by applying some some limit
of an operator uh phi z uh to to to
to a vacuum state ket naught or ket zero
which is so where the vacuum state is
just some state that's invariant under
the action of sl2 z
and uh in the context of one of these
multi-wave systems that that has a very
direct correspondence
that's stating that when we set up the
initial conditions for one of these
multi-wave systems
we can effectively think of the of an of
an initialization event
uh that says you know the empty set maps
onto a if a is the initial condition
and so that so then uh what that means
is so if so for any initial states or
well any state in the multi-evolution
graph can be thought of as being like an
initial state
and so what we're saying is that any
state could have been produced as an
initial state
by an initialization event of the form
empty set goes to that state
and in fact if you want to if you want
to run the code you can see that
explicitly
by running the multi-way system code and
using the option
include initialization events goes to
true which i'm again i'm going to i'm
going to try and demo that in my talk on
thursday
um and so and so this gives you an
immediate way of interpreting the
operative state correspondence in the
context of one of these multi-way
systems
um maybe i'll go through this quickly um
because
yeah this is a bunch of complicated math
that's probably not not ideally suited
for a talk of the structure
but i i wanted to quickly just just
before we finish
mention some some implications that this
interpretation of quantum mechanics has
for things like quantum information
theory so there is a there
the kinesthetics completion problem uh
or completion algorithm uh
is actually is has been investigated a
lot not just in mathematical logic
but also in areas like universal algebra
and computational group theory because
it basically gives you a way if you're
given a finitely presented monoid
it gives you a way of solving the word
problem for that monoid because
if you consider a monad which has a
particular generator set
then you can consider the freemonoid
that's generated by it
which is essentially the set of all
words uh whose elements are taken from
from from that original mono aid
and then the the elements of of that of
the original finitely presented mono
correspond to the equivalence classes of
that that exist in that set of words
under the equivalence relation of of
that of that particular presentation
and so that's exactly a a a sort of an
abstract rewrite system
where the element set is is x star and
where the the uh
where the set of rewrite relations is
given by r by
by the by the presentation of the monoid
and so then
to solve the word problem what we want
to do is we want to find you know for
any
for any individual word that appears in
x star we want to be able to find a
canonical word a representative word
to which we can reduce it um in such a
way that uh you know
in such a way that if if two words
reduce to the same canonical form
then it's guaranteed to be that they're
equivalent the the the the
the that they are equal with respect to
the original group presentation
and so that's that that's essentially
the same problem as is solved by
kinetics completion because what we're
doing is we're saying
you know if we think about this group
presentation as producing an abstract
rewrite system
what we want to do is take that and
reduce it to something that's confluent
so that you know so that we can
guarantee that there is convergence
between these different words
and which is strongly normalizing so
that we can guarantee that there is a
canonical representative word for each
class of words
to which we can reduce it um so here's
you know an
explicit example of that would be you
know if we start from the cayley graph
of
the free group on on on two generators a
and b which i showed actually
uh in my previous talk and then we
consider adding some some relations to
it so if we add the relation the a b
equals b a now we get no a non-free
group which has this kilograph where
there's actually merging between the
states
so you know this is like merging between
between states and a multi-way system
and then what we're trying to do is we
want to know you know given
uh given given to given a pair of words
that exist in this
group uh are they equivalent are are
those words actually the same
and so then so you know as i say what we
want to do is we want to take this
abstract rewrite system and reduce it to
one where the word problem is decidable
and therefore we want to reduce it to
one in which we have confluence and and
strong normalization
and this has also been investigated in
the context of of um
computing what are called groveno bases
for for polynomial rings
uh through through this process called
book burgers algorithm which is
uh developed by bruno blockburger which
is which is this sort of this algebraic
analog of the kinetics completion
algorithm
uh let me not go into too much detail
about how that works the main reason
i wanted to bring this up was to point
out that this completion procedure can
be applied
to a finitely presented monoid because
we can treat a finitely presented monoid
as being like a specification of a
multi-way system now
the reason i bring that up is because
this has a bunch of interesting
implications for
computational complexity theory and in
particular for quantum information
theory
because if you think about this what is
the distinction between an ordinary
touring machine a classical
deterministic turing machine uh and
something like like a quantum turing
machine well in an ordinary classical
turing machine you you know you have
your initial set of states where
where the individual and you have you
have a set of symbols taken from
from some finite from some finite
alphabet
um and then and then you're defining a
partial partial function which is the
transition function
that tells you given a turing machine in
a particular state with a particular
tape state
uh you know what should machine do next
what should what you know what symbol
should it print on the tape
uh and and how should it how should it
evolve it's it's in its internal state
and which direction should it shift to
the should it shift the tape
um then so you know so in the case of a
of a two-two turing machine a two-state
two-color turing machine this is this is
what you get
you know this is this is the this is the
deterministic evolution that you'd see
for one of those turing machines
um if you consider a non-deterministic
turing machine
what's what's essentially happening is
rather than having a a partial function
that is your transition function you
have a partial transition relation
so in other words you know for a given
state of the turing machine
it's not that you have a uniquely
defined future state but you can have a
multitude of future states
so a non-deterministic turing machine is
essentially a touring multi-way system
so that's what we're seeing here if we
if we look at the evolution graph for
i've misspelled the word multi-way there
but if we look at the if we look at the
evolution graphery
for a for all possible two-two turing
machine rules we get a multi-wave
evolution graph in fact we get
we get what's called a rulial multi-wave
evolution graph uh that shows all
possible evolution histories for those
for those two two turing machine rules
and so so that exists because given a
particular state of the turing machine
because we now have instead of having a
partial function we have a partial
relation
there's not a uniquely defined future
state there can be many possible future
states
um so here's and so then a a classical
turing machine corresponds to a
deterministically computed path
through the space of all possible uh
sort of turing machine paths so if we
take
if we take a a multi-way system that
corresponds to a non-deterministic to
the computation of a non-deterministic
turing machine
um then we then we then and if we pick
out a path according to some
deterministic rule
uh what that's doing is we're just we're
just we're calming out some particular
gd sick
i mean actually may or may not be a gd6
depending on the exact details of the
computation but we're picking out a
particular path
through that multi-wave evolution graph
that happens to correspond
to the evolution of a deterministic
turing machine
okay so then what exactly is a quantum
turing machine
well in a quantum turing machine uh what
you're doing is you know the state space
is no longer
it's no longer a discrete space you're
replacing it with a finite dimensional
hilbert space
and you'll replace it so you know your
your initial state is then replaced with
some initial state vector
and instead of having a partial
transition function or a partial
transition relation
you have a partial transition monoid
that that has this general form
and so um in other words what you can
what's essentially happening there is is
it's it's like what's going on in a
nondeterministic turing machine where
there isn't a uniquely defined future
state for any given state of the current
system
but instead of instead of picking a
future state in accordance with some
non-deterministic rule
what you're doing is you're actually
evolving all possible future states
you're evolving
a linear superposition of all possible
states of the turing machine so if
if a if a classical turing machine is a
single evolution path
uh define you know kind of scoped out by
by a deterministic uh
sort of uh updating relation and if a a
non-deterministic turing machine
is a is a is also a single rewrite path
but is it but is kind of scoped out by
some by the application of some
non-deterministic event selection
function
then what a quantum turing machine would
correspond to is the evolution of the
entire multi-wave system itself
it would correspond to the entire
multi-wave evolution graph where we
we're essentially seeing a linear
superposition of all possible states of
the
of the turing machine evolving in time
so and so in other words that's what
we're seeing here so so so
because we've replaced the transition
function by some collection of of
unitary matrices so some collection of
automorphisms of the herbert space
uh it's no longer guaranteed to be the
case that if you know if we start from a
single eigen state then we end up with a
single eigen state it could be this it
could be the case that our collection of
automorphisms
uh takes a single eigenstate and and
sort of and and converts it to
into a linear superposition of two
eigenstates which is what which is
effectively what we're seeing here
so we can think of this this multi-way
system as being like a very
simple specification of the evolution of
a quantum turing machine
okay why is that significant well it
therefore it gives us a way of
actualizing the measurement process in
quantum information theory
because if this interpretation of
quantum mechanics is right if it's
correct
that the measurement procedure in
quantum mechanics can really be thought
of as like a completion procedure
applied to a multi-way system
then what it means is it gives us a
precise way of of describing the process
by which you go from
a state of a quantum computer to a
classical sort of computational state
that you can interpret post measurement
that's something that currently in in
ordinary quantum information theory
is highly mysterious because of course
the measurement process is a non-linear
process
that isn't fully understood it can't be
described you know in terms of the in
terms of unity evolution of the
of the schrodinger equation and so um
so what what this gives us what this
mathematical structure gives us
is a way to actualize the measurement
process in quantum information by saying
take the finitely presented transition
monoid that corresponds to the
to the way that the the quantum turing
machine is evolving
and apply a kinetics completion
procedure to it and what you what you
end up finding
is that the transition monologue reduces
to a partial transition function
and that the hilbert space of states
that you could reach uh
by by you know by by considering the
full multi-way state
uh by the by considering the full
multi-evolution reduces to
exactly the to the set of states that
would be achievable using a classical
turing machine
so that again that gives us another sort
of strong piece of evidence that this
you know this interpretation of quantum
measurement is actually kind of is
actually what's going on in real quantum
mechanics
because it explains how given the final
step in it
you know given that you've you've
evolved your quantum turing machine so
you now have this linear superposition
of of eigenstates
it explains how you were able to go from
that to a classical uh to a you know
to a single unambiguous classical state
that you can interpret as being the
result of some classical computation
because what you're doing is you're just
taking you're taking this branch like
hypersurface
and you're applying a completion
procedure to it and you're collapsing
the thing down to a single eigen state
and again so so so we we can see that we
that there's an immediate correspondence
with the standard mathematical formalism
of quantum information theory that
allows us to reduce the finitely
presented monoid of the quantum turing
machine
down to the to the ordinary transition
function of the classical turing machine
okay uh that's probably uh enough
information for one talk at least for
now i i if people are interested i might
talk more about this
later today or tomorrow if people want
to find out more but obviously
there is another lecture that will cover
more uh in more mathematical detail what
um
you know what what the correspondence is
between uh things like multi-wave
evolution graphs and projective hilbert
spaces
and quite excitingly how you can define
an analog of general relativity
that applies you know whereas general
relativity applies in the ordinary
space-time causal network
if we consider the multi-way causal
network that is the you know that
parameterizes the causal relations not
just between
events on one branch of history but
between events on multiple branches of
history
it turns out you can define an analog of
the einstein equations that acts in the
in the multi-way causal network as well
and the analog of those einstein
equations well
i think as steven already kind of may
have mentioned in his keynote speech the
rather exciting thing that we discovered
was that uh where you get the classical
einstein hilbert action in the case of
the
of the ordinary spacetime causal network
what you end up finding in in the case
of the multi-way causal network
instead of the einstein hilbert action
you end up with a path integral action
and so the relativistic lagrangian
density that you see in in general
relativity
gets replaced with the sort of quantum
field theoretic lagrangian density that
you
that one considers in things like
particle physics um
but uh i i'm not gonna go into into
detail about how we derive that now
so i might as well uh stop talking for a
bit and if people want to
we can we can well if people have any
questions i'm happy to stick around and
answer them but otherwise uh if you want
to take a break before we before we do a
discussion session later on
then we can do that i just had a quick
question
yeah go for it on this i'm trying to
understand
with this completion theory about the
collapse of the wave function
um where does the stochastic part come
in so
i mean the the path as i understand like
the pathways that you showed are
analogous to the um the amplitude
the probability amplitudes right right
and so how does the
how does it follow that the the
eigenstate that
the system collapses into is
uh a you know basically a probability
distribution
on the squared amplitudes of those
pathways
right right okay so there are a couple
of subtleties in that so
one of which is that this is not this
process of measurement is of course not
a probabilistic process as you notice
it's a completely deterministic
algorithm
um and so this interpretation so
necessarily
this is a non this is this is a
determination this is a a
purely deterministic interpretation of
quantum mechanics
um as i will try to describe maybe if i
have time
later tomorrow um that obviously implies
that in order to achieve
uh you know violation of bill's
inequalities you know if we if we're
maintaining determinism then we either
have to violate local realism
we either have to have to violate
realism or we have to violate locality
so um and it turns out that locality
violation is a natural consequence of
these models
so what happens is uh in the multi-way
causal network
um like i say because you have
connections between updating events that
exist not just on one branch of history
but between branches of history
um you're effectively connecting events
that are not just space spatially
separated but also branchially separated
the reason why that's interesting is
because two events that are nearby in
branchial space
don't necessarily have to be nearby in
physical space right because if
it just because a pair of uh just
because a pair of events are
sort of uh branch adjacent
branch like adjacent with respect to the
multi-way causal network doesn't mean
that they're going to be spaced the
associated events will be spaced like
adjacent
in the ordinary space-time causal
network so what that means is
in the multi-way causal network you can
get causal relationships between
between events that appear to be very to
be highly spatially non-local
and so so but but nevertheless are
branchially
local and so still you know they still
satisfy some analog
of of a finite speed of light but they
they're satisfying that that condition
with respect to
to branch your space which corresponds
essentially to a to a finite rate of
entanglement between between eigenstates
so that i mean so that's the um the
reason i
this doesn't answer your question but i
i wanted to preface it by saying that
that this is this is a fundamentally
non-probabilistic model of quantum
mechanics
but nevertheless achieves consistency
with bell's inequalities by essentially
allowing for kind of massive
non-locality as a consequence of having
uh causal edges in the multi-way causal
network
that that can connect events that are
highly spatially separated
okay so but then you do ask a very good
question of
even if it's actually deterministic how
do you go about do
you know how do you quantum mechanics
look
even if you have a purely deterministic
but non-local interpretation of quantum
mechanics
it still looks uh non-deterministic
because of the non-locality how can we
actually see that
um that's a really good question and
basically what it has to do with
actually maybe i can show a picture
so um what it has to do with this is the
fact that even though the completion
procedure is deterministic
it is dependent on the on the observer
it's dependent on the choice of
reference frame
so uh if i show
if i share my screen again okay so
way back when we did the uh foliations
of the multi-way
evolution graph like here okay so this
is this is one foliation this is one you
know
corresponding to one possible sequence
of measurement events that an observer
could could perform one possible
sequence of events
of rewrite events that they could see
but we could consider an observer and in
fact we
we will in in tomorrow's lecture
consider observers who are
who effectively have kind of like
boosted foliations of a multi-way
evolution graph where they see a
different
sequence of measurement events and so
that's important
because the sequence of measurement
events that the observer or the sequence
of states that exist
on that branch like hypersurface is the
uh
sorry it's not a sequence it's it's an
unordered set the set of events
that exist on that branch like
hypersurface uh determines what you know
which events the observer is seeing as
being in superposition which event
which states the observer is seeing as
being in superposition which which
states
the observer sees as being uh as being
sort of
as being the eigen states that exist in
that in that wave function
uh so then when the observer performs a
measurement those are the states with
which they're performing completions
with respects to what that means is
if you had an observer which had a
different which who was seeing a
different collection of
of states in their branch like
hypersurfaces they would perform a
different completion procedure because
instead of attempting to collapse
this branch pair that corresponds to you
know uh aab and aba
they would be attempting to collapse you
know this branch pair corresponding to
aab and abb
which is not a branch pair with respect
to this foliation but would be a branch
pair with respect to some tipped
foliation
where these where these two states were
treated as being equivalent
um so in other words the
so even though the completion once you
have a foliation the completion
procedure is deterministic
but it's non-deterministic at the level
of what
what your observer is if you make a
parametrized change of observer
which is like the analog of a lorentz
boost in the multi-way evolution graph
you will see a different eigenstate you
will see a different outcome of that
measurement operation
and so the reason you get probabilities
coming out is precisely
okay it's deeply related to this
averaging process that we had to do in
the causal network so
you'll remember when we were doing
einstein when we were doing the einstein
equation derivations in the causal
network
to derive continuum equations what we
had to do is average out
over all possible time-like projections
which is like averaging out over all
possible
uh choices of foliation or possible
local gauge choices
to derive the path integral we have to
do exactly the same thing we have to we
have to average out over all possible
local observers all possible choices
of branch-like hypersurfaces and so um
so so when we do that what we're doing
is you know what
you're averaging out of all possible
completion procedures that you could
have applied
and therefore all possible sort of eigen
states that you could have you could
have observed as the outcome to that
measurement
and so so what you get is something that
looks statistical it looks like
uh like like the measurement process was
probabilistic but that's only
but that's only reflecting the fact that
you're having to take an average of
all possible observers if you're a
single observer you know
seeing a particular sequence of branches
like hypersurfaces then then everything
about the measurement process is is
fully is fully deterministic
so so the stochasticity that you're kind
of uh you're alluding to
arises precisely from the fact that that
you know there is the canonical observer
there isn't a there isn't a canonical
reference frame uh like a cosmological
reference frame
for for the multigrain evolution graph
it it you know it's observer dependent
and the observer dependence
is is the in is way is where the
uh where the probabilistic nature of the
measurement effectively comes from
i i hope that answers your question i
can perhaps make a more more precise
version of that
if you're interested but that's the
basic idea
this is less the question about the
material and more just kind of a request
uh can you provide any like resources on
that uh
newt bennett algorithm yes yeah yeah
okay so sure
um i uh yes there are plenty there's
actually i think daniel um i don't know
if daniel sanchez is here yes he is
uh daniel recommended in the physics
chats which i think is a great
recommendation this this thing called
term rewriting and and that
uh term rewriting and all that which is
a kind of a
general reference book on uh a bunch of
techniques and ideas and algorithms from
abstract rewriting theory and terminal
writing theory and it's kind of it's
well it's the place where i learned
uh things about things like the kinetics
completion procedure
um i will post a link to that i will see
if there's it's possible to get a pdf
and i'll post a link to that in the in
the resources channel later on
uh but yeah let's do it i have a pdf
oh you do okay i don't know
have you already sent it in or can you i
will
perfectly okay awesome thank you so much
um i i would also have a question yeah
do you think that it could be somehow
constructed i mean a measurement not
just interpreted in a in a way but also
constructed some kind of structure
in this in the system which would
actually
make and behave like a like a
measure measurement apparatus
yes um so that's something we've looked
into
and again i i if i have time i might try
and discuss that a little bit tomorrow
um the the basic answer as
as with so many of these questions is we
haven't looked at it and looked at it
in as much detail as we would like but
the the basic idea is
okay um uh in fact steven might have a
might have a nice picture of this
so um no actually i know he has a nice
picture of it let me see if i can
actually find it
uh so
um the basic idea is you can use kind of
the the analog
of um of gravitational lensing to
essentially force convergence of gd6 in
the multi-way evolution graph which is a
slightly crazy sound i think an abstract
idea
but um it's something that we're trying
to make precise
and where ah there we go there it is
okay let me share my screen
so in steven's uh technical
technical exposition there's this
example of a sort of
one of these foliations of a multi-wave
evolution graph which kind of freezes
time around a particular collection of
states
uh and actually this is this is there's
a better example okay
here's a better example so here's a
here's a multi-evolution graph
where there's there is a normal form and
in which you so so in order to in order
to get around having that normal form
there
you're essentially having to freeze time
around that state like you would for a
for a space-time singularity
in the causal network so the idea
would be that when you set up a measure
a piece of measurement apparatus
it's like you're setting up a you know
the analog of a
of a black hole but in in multi way in
the in the branchial space in
in the multi-wave evolution graph rather
than in the causal network
so the reason why that would why that
would kind of actualize or
mechanize this this measurement process
is
essentially so what would happen is if
if you had a if you had a singularity
that was kind of it was
cloaked in some in some branchial event
horizon and it was and
was effectively producing uh
convergences of gd6 like you like you
would get with gravitational lensing
around
uh you know around an ordinary
space-time black hole
well the convergence of gd6 is is the
state it
is essentially the convergence of branch
pairs right because a a ged stick in the
multi-way evolution graph it's just
it's just a rewrite sequence it's you
know a sequence of updating events
and so if two if you have a pair of gd6
that would otherwise have diverged but
which now because of the presence of
that
of that kind of branchy or black hole
the presence of that singularity
are now forced to converge that's like
you're imposing a completion procedure
and so this notion that you can
construct both physical and coordinate
singularities in in branchial space
is our current sort of conjectural idea
of how this measurement process is
actually is sort of actualized
uh in these systems but by some analog
of gravitational lensing but
that's a process that we don't uh yeah
we don't understand it's still it's
still very much a
sort of a hypothetical idea
maybe maybe i'm getting this wrong but
but
doesn't it mean that the
the end of the of the measurement the
result of the measurement would depend
actually on the
on the updating event
structure so
what do you mean by i'm a bit confused
so so
confluence means that in some way
the the order of updatings is not
relevant yes
right however if we have a black hole in
a branch or
space doesn't it mean that it is
actually relevant in that in that model
yes absolutely because because you're
saying that that branch terminates at a
normal form but
you know other branches don't
is that what you're saying yeah no no i
completely agree so yes so definitely i
mean having a normal form
if you if you have one branch that
reaches a normal form and none of the
other branches do that's like that's the
minimal case
of a system where you definitely can't
have confluence um
so yeah if you had a if you had a branch
your black hole that was kind of
maintained
and just stuck there as as a as a normal
form
then yes absolutely that would that
would correspond to a global violation
of confluence
the point is in order to have effective
confluence
you have to construct a a foliation
that's that avoids the presence of you
know
okay like in ordinary space time right
when if you if you have the presence of
a gravitational singularity
um because because that gravitational
singularity is just a is a topological
puncture in your in your manifold
any foliation you construct in some
initial value formulation of gr
has to essentially avoid the presence of
that singularity
you have to construct some reference
frame so you know some foliation of the
space time that essentially avoids the
presence of that singularity
what we're arguing is that you have to
do the same thing that if you want to
have a system that ha
that doesn't depend on the details of
the updating order
your foliation has to somehow avoid ever
reaching the normal form
uh because if because as you say if you
had a foliation that did reach the
normal form
then you know immediately you violated
confluence but to construct a foliation
that avoids the normal form
is equivalent we claim to saying that
you're applying a completion procedure
um we we have only kind of spotty
heuristic evidence for
for actually stating that we don't we
certainly don't have a formal proof of
it but that's that's the essential idea
but doesn't it mean that then you want
to avoid
measurement uh no
no no because no
you you want to avoid the the the
measurement is
what happens when you construct that
foliation
the the measurement is is the it's the
set of equivalences you have to you have
to apply
in order in order to avoid the whole
system from terminating at that normal
form
okay i need to wrap around that my
my head still and okay
okay uh and uh can can we say that
basically
um this
this black hole uh formation in in
branchial space this is basically it can
be interpreted as a
[Music]
many world interpretation if we if we
don't take
one branch but we take all of branches
then
it's basically compatible with the many
world interpretation
absolutely absolutely it's it's a yeah
this this way of treating you know
unitary evolution of
bronze like hypersurfaces as being a
multi-wave evolution graph
that's very much a many worlds kind of
story it just it gives us a way of more
precisely actualizing
claims about you know interference
between branches and measurements
uh that you know the collapse branches
down than exists in the standard you
know everetti and deutsche
uh model of the many worlds
interpretation but yes absolutely it's
it's very much compatible
um oh nick are you are you raising your
hand is that
yeah yeah i have a question concerning
measurement
so that's the requirement for observer
to be effectively large part of the
hapagar space
assigns some kind of limit on the size
of those particle obstructions in it
so that they can perform measurements
from each other
oh that's an interesting question um i
don't know
i mean it's it's such a wishy-washy
heuristic claim that i made that it's
it's hard to make any definitive
statements um
it it almost certainly does yeah i mean
it's
it knowing more about the measurement
process will will
as you say undoubtedly will give us ways
of estimating the effective length scale
of discretization it will give us ways
of estimating the size of particles and
the size of observers and so on
in terms of elementary hyperedges um
but uh we don't understand the
measurement process i mean as
as is evident from from the exchange
with joseph we don't understand the
measurement process in enough detail to
be able to do that yet
um it's the reason you know the main
reason for making this claim that the
observer has to be macroscopic
is um okay this is going to this is
going to get a little bit
weird and philosophical but the the the
one one intuition for for kind of why
that has to be the case is
the observer wants to construct a causal
invariant representation of the world
they want to be not confused
about which branch of history happened
they want to see a single thread of
history
but that's but in reality there's this
whole multi-way evolution
there's this whole multi-wave system of
possible histories so how do they go
about taking this multi-way system
and and reducing it down to something
that for them they can represent in a
causal and variant way
well the idea would be in order for
their
model of the world to be causal and
variant you know at the very least
there has to be effective causal
invariants within the observer itself
the observer has to perform a completion
procedure at least within their own
uh within their own local structure in
order to
prevent themselves from being confused
and then the idea would be
that if the observer is large enough
that they cause that they that
the the hypograph structure of the
observer constitutes like a
statistically significant uh sort of
sample of the of the hypograph structure
of the rest of the universe
then the same completion rules that
would cause the observer's
wave function to collapse would also
cause the rest of the universe's wave
function to collapse
and therefore it's meaningful to say
that there is effective deterministic
evolution of the universe that's a
but like i said it's a very hand-wavy
wishy-washy claim
um but it's uh it's the it's kind of the
best we have at the moment
um there is a more mathematically
precise way of of actualizing
this measurement process in terms of um
in terms of these
in terms of collapsing between in terms
of collapsing events in branch-like
hypersurfaces
that doesn't require this assumption
about the about sort of macroscopic
nature of the observer
but i just thought from a from a purely
philosophical point of view that was a
nice way of thinking about kind of what
the observer is and
why the observer therefore enforces
something like completion procedure why
the observer enforces a course grainy
um so yeah that's a great question about
using effective scales of the observer
to estimate you know scales of
particle interactions and things that's
something i hadn't really thought about
but it's a neat idea
um i don't think we can i don't think
we're in a position to do it yet but
that's a nice thought
um maybe maybe still about this
measurement process
um so does it mean that
from predictability point of view
this is a non-deterministic model from
the point of view of an observer living
inside this this world
yes yeah i i think so i think um because
the observer can't know the kind of
global gauge conditions for their own
quantum reference frame
um yes i think it's correct to say that
therefore they can't know
in detail what completion procedures
they're actually
they're actually performing and so it
wouldn't in principle be possible for
them to predict what the outcome
of measurement would be so yes i i think
that's right i think i think because
um you know in the same way as uh
um yeah i mean essentially for reasons
of the equivalence principle right that
um just like in okay in ordinary general
relativity right you have the
equivalence principle which says
um you can't tell you as an observer
just embedded within space time cannot
tell the difference
between between a kind of um
you know an accelerating reference frame
and a gravitational reference frame or
to be a bit more
mathematically precise what that means
is you can't tell the difference between
a pathology that exists in your own
coordination of space-time
and an actual geometrical uh pathology
that exists in the space time itself
and so uh i guess the the analog of the
equivalence principle here
would say you can't tell the difference
between if you you know you're seeing a
particular sequence of branch like
hypersurfaces
you can't tell whether that sequence
which aspects of that sequence are
determined by your choice of reference
frame
and which aspects of that sequence are
determined by the actual underlying
geometry of branchial space
and the point is in order to be able to
predict the outcome of a measurement
you need to know what your own quantum
reference frame is
and so the the analog of the equivalence
principle would indicate what would
imply that
um yeah that effectively that that
information is observationally
inaccessible to you so i think that's i
think that's true
so can i think of this as being
basically the same as
uh just normal interpretation of
interpretation of quantum mechanics
but i'm using numpy.random to
get a pseudo-random number every time i
have to resolve it
observation and i just can't know the
seed
i guess yeah
yeah it's uh interesting yes this is
yeah interpreting the
details of the quantum observation frame
as being the seed for some student
random number generator is a
that's a that's a nice way of thinking
about it i like that analogy
um uh what what the pseudo random number
generator is
is less clear whether it's you know
whether it's the same as the
pseudo-random number
number generator used in numpy but um
but yeah i i think i think effectively
that is a nice way of thinking about it
but that's yeah
that's a nice analogy
um okay with any other i mean we have
ostensibly a discussion session
scheduled in like half an hour or
something
so we we can all come back and uh you
know
formulate some questions and break
breakout rooms and discuss them then but
uh did anyone
before we before we go and take a break
for a little while did anyone have any
any
any pressing issues they wanted to bring
up
hey jonathan not a physics issue but
um something about how to organize the
the discussions so yes uh
yeah what we did uh during the morning
was
so we had uh so we created
uh at least uh i did that i think that
danielle also
did that so we started to
uh threads in the physics uh channel for
people to have the questions there and
and you can see the questions then so
we were wondering if so i was thinking
that maybe we don't want to spam the
physics
channel with these um threads
yeah maybe having a channel just for the
for the discussions right what what do
you guys think
i mean in general this is a question for
the students are you comfortable with
having a threat for your breakout rooms
and having the questions there
silence speaks a lot so i will take that
as a yeah
like a physics q a
something like that i guess yeah
okay we're getting a couple of green
votes from luigi and cameron
okay um yeah so i think i can create
uh a channel i i have to
i still need to ask vitali about that uh
but
i think for now it's fine if we use the
physics channel
um let's just create threads
for every breakout room how many record
runs
um did we have during the morning four
maybe i think i made five but maybe we
should make more i mean we
i i don't know i'm not sure how i mean
my impression was that that
worked better than it did yesterday but
it still wasn't great i don't know if
that was that was the impression that
other people had um
but so i do you think more breakout
rooms is the solution or fewer or
just less breakout room time or how can
we organize this better
please ideas all right so
let me see let me see the schedule so we
have the
yeah i think there i mean this is a
little too short for
for the discussion especially if we only
have like we have
five uh breakout rooms but when we have
one jonathan right
um or do we have more jana dancer on
there
on different branches of the multi-way
system maybe yeah
[Laughter]
all right so my my suggestion will be to
so to have um the threats with the
questions there
like in in the case in in the room uh i
was uh we had uh joseph who
who also um contributed to the
discussion
and but the questions that are
unanswered
can be also part of the q a so that's
more like
like like the live streams like when you
read the questions and you
answer the questions there with people
in the audience so
i think we can try that yeah i mean that
sounds great to me
are you sure you're okay to organize
that is that something you can you can
do
certainly say again sorry are you are
you sure you're able to organize that
that seems like i i don't want to place
too much work on you
yeah sure i mean yeah yeah i mean i can
i can make a thread for
every breakout room just let me know how
many rooms uh you're gonna make because
i think if i'm not a host i i can't see
how many
rooms oh yeah okay uh i actually i
should see if i can make you co-host
when we when we do it again that would
yeah that makes sense
okay no i like that idea and and you and
you think the idea i mean
do people generally think the idea of
just like collating questions and then
feeding them back to me is that like
is that the optimal structure or should
we do it in a different way
um i feel like so if we had like a
channel
so just specifically for breakout rooms
so it would be like just hashtag
breakout rooms and then
um because the lectures are at different
times so then it would be organized
that way and then so all what you would
have to do jonathan if you were
sitting in a one breakout room you could
look at the other questions being
discussed in
different threads which correspond to
different breakout rooms
so then you could hop in between if you
see something that you're interested in
or
um just to like see where the
conversation is going in different
breakout rooms
that that sounds fine to me but i i'm
just
i'm what i don't know i i'm perfectly
happy with that but
i think i think we should have just a
channel for for the
for a discussions like uh yeah like hash
break
breakout rooms or something like that i
just want to double check with vitali
before i uh do something
i don't have to do on slack
yeah i'm sure he'll be okay with it yeah
so
like for for now i i guess we can still
use a physics channel and i think the
cool thing of having the
the threads and the questions there is
that uh
i suspect we may get
very similar questions in some rooms so
we can then see what kind of questions
uh are common between
uh the audience i agree yeah
okay i mean does anyone so does anyone
have a oh sorry
just what what is my role precisely here
uh well you you can you can help run run
discussions
okay okay if that's okay with you
that's okay with me just uh i want to
highlight that i'm not an
expert on the quantum uh
side of the buffer model no no that's
fine you're just meant to be there as
like the adult supervision for each
breakout room
okay maybe that's i can manage that and
try and just
you know obviously try to guide
discussion in interesting directions
yeah okay all right so i guess
erin will take a break get back
at the main room you'll make the
breakout rooms
and i'll just make a thread for uh every
room
sounds awesome okay we'll see how it
goes all right all right
thanks so much everyone i talk to you
soon bye